this is jocko podcast number 294 with
echo charles and me jocko willink good
evening echo good evening
flight
this is blue star six rp major bunting
announced as he crossed the release
point on the ground indicating two
minutes flight time to the landing zone
with that announcement charlie gunships
from crossbows began a slow dive toward
the landing zone prepared to release
some of the 14 2.75
inch rockets that each aircraft carried
along with their machine guns if it
became necessary
flight lead is taking fire
blue star 6 announced over the uhf
frequency which was obvious to everyone
behind him as the green tracers were
coming from all around him chalk 2 is
taking fire we're hit came the next
announcement
suddenly the radio was alive with every
aircraft reporting taking fire as they
crossed the rp and the woods around the
landing zone were highlighted by red and
white flashes and green tracers
streaming upward
as each aircraft flew into the cone of
fire attempting to reach the landing
zone and discharge their load the
airwaves became garbled as pilots
stepped on each other's transmission or
in panic depressed their transmit switch
to the entire flight
so they could everyone could hear the
conversation between a pilot and his
crew chock six is taking [ __ ] get on
your guns chock five where's the damn
guns break break chalk ten is
there was so much confusion that no one
could get a complete sentence
transmitted until
may day may day dutch master 4-1 is
going down
said captain fox in almost a calm voice
who the hell is dutch master 4-1 someone
asked over the radio looking skyward and
searching everyone had their answer
dutch master 4-1 was the command and
control aircraft for the cav screen and
was entering an auto rotation from 4 000
feet
what really held everyone's attention
was the flames coming out of the bottom
of the aircraft oh [ __ ]
it was obvious that he'd taken a hit
with an explosive round in the fuel cell
but at 4 000 feet
every aircraft had at least one set of
eyes tracking this crippled aircraft an
aircraft in flight on fire was somehow
few something few had ever seen before
and it was horrifying and mesmerizing
may day dutch master 4-1 is on fire was
the next call from captain fox his voice
a bit elevated
fire was every aviator's worst nightmare
shoot me but don't let me burn
there was a fear that had been with
aviators since orville and wilbur had
first flown
before parachutes world war one pilots
were known to use their pistols rather
than burn in an aircraft
as everyone watched the radios went
silent
slowly dutch master 4-1 began a slow
roll
and as it hit the trees it was inverted
the cavs screen began to converge on the
crash site
as major bunton bunting entered the
cauldron of enemy fire
he turned to mr grossman get on the
controls with me in case i'm hit
grossman immediately did so that with a
very light touch
ready to take command of the aircraft
suddenly sauer and thomas opened fire
taking fire they both screamed together
though there was no need since the sound
of a hammer tapping on the side of the
aircraft could clearly be heard as blue
star six continued to press toward the
landing zone decelerating and coming to
a hover
the arvind soldiers didn't wait for the
aircraft to land they started jumping
out as the aircraft came to a slow walk
before major bunting could land the
aircraft was empty sir go go we're empty
sauer yelled as he continued to fire his
weapon at the tree line
choco one on the go major bunting
transmitted lz is hot
his next transmission followed almost
immediately
may day may day
blue star 6 is going in
he had just cleared the landing zone
when the aircraft engine quit
and that right there is an excerpt
from
book three from a series of books called
undaunted valor
which were written by colonel matt
jackson
and this is the third book of the series
which is
subtitled lamsan
and the first book that he wrote in this
series was subtitled an assault
helicopter squadron in vietnam 1969 to
1970 and we had the honor of covering
that book
with colonel jackson on this podcast it
was podcast number 275
and that first book is based on colonel
jackson's
experiences himself as in vietnam as a
huey pilot
the huey the iconic helicopter of the
vietnam war
and that first book
it's written as a novel
or a story with the main character the
main character is named dan corey but
that character is based on colonel
jackson and
the events that are in the book took
place and this third book is written
in a similar way it's written
from the from the perspective are
focused on a an individual named dan
corey
but
the the events that are written about in
this third book they took place
and it
continues to recount some of these
incredible heroics
from these helicopter pilots and
helicopter crews in vietnam and this
third book in the series tells the story
of a
of a massive operation
which included the largest helicopter
assault of the vietnam war this is an
operation that lasted 45 days it was cut
conducted in laos and it was an attempt
to shut down the ho chi minh trail
and
this book undaunted valor lambson 719
is filled with incredible details
that colonel jackson got by interviewing
and doing intense research to accurately
describe what happened
and the book is incredible read
but we're actually not going to
read the book much today we're going to
touch on a little bit
because we have the honor of having
one of the pilots
who
also flew hughes in vietnam and who flew
missions in support of operation lamsan
his name is jay tate
he's a retired major u.s army
he is the recipient of two distinguished
flying crosses 38 air medals recognizing
950 hours of combat flying
the bronze star the vietnamese cross of
gallantry
and the silver star for his heroic
actions under fire
it was an honor honor to have him here
with us tonight
jay
thank you for joining us well
well that introduction was uh
put me right back in the cockpit
the and that book is filled with those
those either coming into landing zones
or coming out of landing zones it's just
incredible to read and incredible to
learn about the history of that
operation
as a matter of fact i was talking to a
friend of mine that was in um that was
in in sag in vietnam and i mentioned
that you were coming on the podcast
and i told him that you flew in lambson
719 he and the look on his face is whoa
that was a that was a rough one
you know
we supported command and control north
which was the northern segment of sog in
in vietnam
and
i remember several missions that we flew
prior to
the kickoff of lamson 719 on 8 february
prior to that we were flying out of the
quantri dongha area with a group of
command and controlled north guys from
up there
flying
west
towards caisson
when all of a sudden in our flight of
four
we saw these orange fireballs coming up
at us
and we immediately took evasive action
23 millimeter
an aircraft fire coming up at us
we took
action to get out of there obviously
the mission at that moment was called
off and we made it back to donghae
one of the guys over torqued his
aircraft
in the evasive action
and
had to be
grounded for inspection for tail rotor
to make sure that nothing had happened
that would cause him further damage or
even crashing
but that was in january of 71 before the
kickoff of 8 february 71
well before we get into that let's talk
a little bit about the beginning of of
jta where where'd you grow up where'd
you come from
i grew up in a little town called
hickory north carolina i was born in
pensacola my father was a flying chief
in the navy flew pb wise
his he was in charge of a hangar at
pensacola that repaired the skin on pbys
that was shot up
and dad would take him up and
fly what we call the idiot circle around
the airfield and land it and check to
make sure the rivets were holding okay
on the aircraft so he was an enlisted
chief
pilot in the navy yep oh that's pretty
good he had a background and uh in
aviation uh well not an aviation
metalsmith but in it was it was a
metalsmith himself and did a lot of work
with sheet metal and stuff like that
so obviously it was uh it was a skill
that the navy needed and dad was a real
smart guy and picked up on it and uh i
loved flying and got his wings i
remember his wings or had a gold center
with the silver wings
which was different than the regular
aviator who has all several wings in the
navy or going
yeah yeah so uh he was he was kind of uh
disappointed i didn't go in the navy but
when i went into army aviation uh that
sort of smoothed it over for him how
long did he do in the navy
uh he was just a guy that went in in
1942 after pearl harbor
and uh got out in 45 and served uh the
rest of his time in the reserves uh got
out of the reserves right after the
korean war
so he was his own businessman he was
going to say for a living yeah he was um
he was a full-time firefighter
for the city of hickory north carolina
and he also owned his own business he
had a shell service station it's called
tate shell service station
and i remember uh he had uh tate shell
it was in great big letters uh
illuminated letters on top of the
service station
and the s uh letter burned out and had
tate hell up there
and
so dad would do a few commercials and uh
on the radio and he said business has
been really good we have sold the s out
of hell
[Laughter]
nice and so uh what about mom she the
the uh what was she doing mom was uh was
a typical housewife
uh
brought me up uh to stay at home uh i
grew up in a neighborhood where nobody
locked their doors we could go on
vacation for two weeks doors to stay
open
um
i remember one time
we had a fire in our home
burned up all it was in the closet
burned up all of mother's clothes
and they had no way of getting in touch
with us because we didn't have cell
service back then
but i remember all the ladies in the
neighborhood came down and had the house
completely cleaned up when we arrived
home except for the fact that mother's
clothes were all burned up but she got
the insurance and got the ball on your
wardrobe
well that's not a bad that's the kind of
neighborhood i grew up in nice what what
about you what were you interested in
what what were you doing when you were a
kid okay um
in our and it's
it's quite ironic in our neighborhood we
had a field that was vacant
and uh we called it the battlefield
and um you have to understand
this was in the early 50s and all of our
parents had served in some
form of military service we had some
marines we had navy we had an army
didn't have any air force but we did
have a navy pilot that was there so we
would all put on the gear that our
fathers brought home and would play army
up in our battlefield
and uh
and from uh
we would dig foxholes
and uh we would make our own hand
grenades but we couldn't pronounce hand
grenades so we called them hankernates
and the hankernake was we
we would dig up uh red clay in in north
carolina and uh would put water on it
and fashion in the balls and let it sit
out in the sun
and then we would throw that as those at
the enemy
and i remember one time eric schufer got
a black eye and his mother was not real
happy that we were playing battlefield
and throwing hand grenades
and then what about as you got older as
i got older
i really wanted to go to a military
school
and
my parents were not quite i was an older
kid so my parents were not quite ready
to let me go
um
i got into the scouts got to wear the
uniform see that was very important to
me then wearing the uniform wearing it
correctly
um in high school
i got into the band i was a drummer
but the uniforms were all
shaped like the
tailored after the west point uniforms
with the high collars and and uh
and
to me that was just added to the uh
the desire to want to do something in
uniform didn't want to be a firefighter
my father was but didn't care to be a
firefighter my uncle
was a police officer didn't care about
being a police officer but there was
something about the military that
that
was like a magnet to me i would watch
every as a child i would watch every
movie
a military movie on tv that would come
on randolph scott you know played those
big he-man marine you know
kind of like you you know except you
were in the navy uh but
those things i gravitated toward that my
good friend
don murphy who i grew up with
he did the same thing he went to the
marine corps
um and
it was really he went the nco route i
was the officer out so at the times when
we would be on leave and come home at
the same time
i had to go through this whole rigmarole
about being an officer
and then list the men really knew what
was going on and we were just there for
showmanship
when uh so what year did you graduate
from high school i graduated in 63. um
quite interestingly
i had
tried out for the united states of
america high school band
as a drummer and was offered a trip so
we
this is these are two to four students
from every state in the union
and
we met at university of southern
mississippi to practice and then we
toured all down through the south across
over into mexico
doing concert tours
all the way to hollywood we did a uh we
did a big concert in the hollywood bowl
and i mean how many people can say that
you know and again in those outstanding
uniforms that were similar to the ones
that i wore band uniforms that i wore in
high school
um and so it just added to the to the uh
and i was proud of that i was very proud
to wear that uniform and i wore it right
and i spit shine my shoes i did that all
the way from junior high school when i
was in the band all the way through high
school so i knew how to spit shine
but then i was
offered a full scholarship
to university of southern mississippi
and also the university of west virginia
uh i didn't like west virginia because
it's everything was hills it seemed like
everywhere you went you had to go up a
hill
and i know you navy guys
you like that stuff but but you know
i wasn't quite into that so i took the
scholarship to southern mississippi
uh their
rotc was mandatory for freshmen and
sophomores and so there again here i was
in uniform not only and i was a the
scholarship i was in at university of
southern mississippi was a full
full-ride music scholarship and i was a
drummer in the university of southern
mississippi band
[Music]
after my first year i decided i didn't
want to be a music major
um
so i thought well you know uh i think
i'll go into art design because i like
to be creative in this
so um
i transferred out of southern
mississippi to my father's dismay
because it was all paid for
and i enrolled in east tennessee state
university in johnson city tennessee
and there
again sophomore year
that was in my sophomore year rotc
mandatory but the more i got into it the
the more i just really gravitated
towards that
and
i took my oath of office
as a an advance corps cadet
as a junior
and
and from there on it's just
i cared more about getting in that
commission than i did about getting my
degree
i had transferred majors
from music to uh art design
so and that time we were on the quarter
system so i had to go an extra quarter
uh
to take up all the courses that i needed
to take and i graduated december at 67.
first went down the aisle and cap and
gown and uh
then i uh
after i got my diploma then all the
cadets go out take off the cap and gown
and we put on our uh uniform coats we
already had the pants and
stuff on for that so under the gowns
so i came down and we were all
commissioned and i remember my mom and
dad pinning those gold bars on my
shoulder boy i tell you what i uh i felt
like i had really accomplished uh at
least the first phase of my life so that
was 1967.
december of 67
i went on active duty
in
march of 68
as an infantry officer
brand new what we call butter bar
wearing the gold bar as a second
lieutenant
i went to the infantry school it's
called the infantry officers basic
course
at fort benning
just on the other side of the hill from
us were all the ocs guys
they called ocs the benning school for
boys
and i'll never forget we were so here we
were
commissioned officers and there they
hoping to be commissioned officers
and many times we would march by their
their area and i re recall a big
telephone poll and on top of the
telephone pole in the officer candidate
school area
was this black
helmet shiny black helmet
with a gold bar in the center of the
helmet it was actually a helmet liner
and
the what they were trying to ocs guys
that was competition who could get up
there and get the helmet first of course
the pole was always greased
and uh i don't know if anybody ever got
up there and got that helmet without
putting cleats on their shoes but at any
rate uh
uh but yeah that's uh
that was my first taste at benning of
being a real army officer so this is
1967 so you must have pretty much known
as an infantry officer you were going to
end up going to vietnam uh yeah i was uh
i was ready i was prepared i was uh
mentally prepared
while at east tennessee state i was a
member of the sigma phi epsilon
fraternity
practically every one of the advanced
core cadets juniors and seniors were uh
advan army uh advanced corps army rotc
cadets and every one this my fraternity
was a big military fraternity
um and we uh we took great pride in that
uh and uh
i i remember we would inspect each other
in the fraternity house before we would
leave to go to drill on thursdays just
to make sure everybody was dressed right
dress ready front
and uh
and it was a it was an it was an honor
uh
to be uh an advanced core cadet and you
had all of these underclassmen that this
was our that you were leading this was
our first time as really being a leader
giving commands uh
moving orders for uh platoon and company
drill and
and and this kind of stuff and so
they were instilling in us they being
the cadre was instilling us
the correct way of
of being an officer of showing authority
without disrespecting people
and you can correct people without
disrespecting people and
and i learned that
through rotc
and that's kind of kind of interesting
because i know that rotc cadets coming
out and being commissioned
didn't have the greatest reputation
amongst a lot of the ncos in the army at
that time
so when it's 1967 and you mentioned that
everyone freshman and sophomore had to
be in rotc it was mandatory at uh at
university of southern mississippi and
it was mandatory at east tennessee state
university i can't speak for the other
uh colleges and universities but i would
think that
perhaps that was
the manner in which uh every university
at least of a federally funded
university uh had to operate
wow
that's pretty so what about what about
like uh
as far as kind of the social
aspects of america at the time where you
started in 1967 you were you really
seeing much of the anti-war
attitude or anything like that no not we
were not subjected to that
i don't recall that
i recall that on campus uh
there was no snickering when in uniform
every thursday was drill day and so
everyone had to show up for drill day
had to be in proper uniform um
if you were a sophomore uh or a freshman
or sophomore uh you were carrying the m1
grand raffle and every week uh as a
freshman sophomore you had to go to the
arms room and clean your weapon and it
had to be
and you see you were taking rotc for
credit
so
for the two years as freshman sophomore
you were taking rotc for credit so yeah
you best uh clean your weapon because if
you didn't you get a demerit and
x number of demerits means you got a
drop in grade
so
we would actually go through and do
inspection before uh
on every drill meet which is on
thursdays
and uh that's how i learned how to
inspect an m1 garand rifle
and uh i don't know if you ever fired
one of those
but uh i think i actually have fired one
i think i actually have i fired a bunch
of different weapons i'm sure we do like
these familiarization shoots and they
pull out a bunch of old weapons and new
weapons and
i can't but i'm pretty sure i have fired
one
but they used to have this uh when you
would clean your rifle when you pull the
bolt back
and you would have to clean down through
the board and everything and then what
you would do is you would take
the little white uh cloth that you used
to stick on the on the bore rod to clean
clean the uh clean the bore out but
you'd stick it down there and you'd look
through and the light from that would
shine up through and you could tell
whether or not you had any uh any
materials in the board that shouldn't be
there
and uh but then you had to
you had to
pull back on um
on the uh
the charging handle yes and then let it
go right quick so it would go forward
well if you didn't let it go right quick
you would get what's called m1 thumb
because it would get stuck right
and many times i had him one thumb
on that yeah but
so uh so you go to the infantry course
that would you call the basic infantry
course infantry officers basic course
iobc
so when when you're in that i mean you
must be these guys are preparing you to
go be
a platoon leader in vietnam correct
correct yeah 1542 platoon leader and and
this is now is it 1968 1968 now so
there's a lot of experienced guys that
are teaching you a lot
a lot how long was that course of
instruction
nine weeks
if i think correctly was it nine weeks
or 16 weeks
ah
i think it was
might have been 12 weeks i'd have to
think about that because i took my first
command at bragg
i was there in uh in march and i took my
first command at bragg in uh in uh
around uh
august so when you're going through that
course are you get forming up platoons
and you're going out and doing training
missions and that kind of thing yeah
that's exactly right uh forming in
platoons and companies and then they
rotated who was going to be platoon
leader i mean we're all second
lieutenants uh well not all of us uh we
had some direct commission guys in there
um i had a i had a sergeant major who
was direct commissioned to a captain oh
wow and uh special forces guy
and uh snake eater and uh
and uh he um
he was always the company commander
and great guy wonderful guy but we would
switch roles around um
we participated in all different kinds
of maneuvers
whether it be
an armored column with infantry in it or
whether it be uh squad tactics uh
whether it be platoon tactics or whether
it was in uh
a company crossing over
what what then they called the
line of departure the ld uh we don't
have that
in warfare now everything
there is no ld it's like perimeter
defense and we're we're going to that
but we practice all of that uh not
everybody went airborne but uh we all
did the
the was a 47-foot tower
that dropped you out and so you get a
feel for what falling with a shoot on is
like and uh
but when i was on a night combat compass
course
and there was uh four of us we went out
teams of four
pouring down rain
at fort benning georgia
columbia columbus georgia
and uh
it was in the early spring
and it was cold as hell
and we were sitting there chattering and
it was a night combat compass course we
were dropped off at a point on a road in
a deuce and a half and
all right
team alpha out so we would get out and
we knew where we were had a postmark
with a number on it and we had our map
so we knew where we were
and then we hunt our directions okay
you're you're you're point a
uh you gotta be at point b and you have
to shoot your azimuth looking at your
map see what shoot your asmus with that
and then uh go to point b and then you
go to point b to point c but pouring
down rain
cold tea chattering only one guy in our
four smoked
so we would have him
light a cigarette
and put it in his mouth and he would go
out following the azimuth
until we would tell him to stop and
light it so that we could make
correction okay go two feet to your
right two feet to your left so that he
was directly on azimuth and then he
would stand there with his cigarette lit
so and puffing under so we could see the
light and then we would go to him then
we'd shoot the next aspect exactly the
same way send him out and guess what
we made it we made it we were one of the
first teams to make it through that
night combat compass course of course
along the way
there were little surprises like
an explosion would happen over maybe
20 meters to our right so we'd have to
go down well it was all planned as to
where this stuff was going to go and we
didn't realize it but you know there
were seasoned troops out there taking
care of us they weren't going to let us
get hurt
we didn't know that at the time but uh
but
during that night
compass course pouring down rain
i heard in the background
it got louder and louder and louder and
louder and louder and finally
straight over our heads
two huey aircraft
and i said to myself those guys are dry
they have it better than i do
a couple days later
in our company area they had a
sign up
anyone interested in army aviation we're
going to be given the flight aptitude
test on a certain date
i was the first in the orderly room to
sign up for that thing
and then that was it you got picked up
for it
graduated from uh benning took my first
command at fort bragg i was in uh
interesting here i am an infantry
officer and my command was a military
and was with a military intelligence
battalion am i battalion here i am an
empty officer i'll never forget my first
sergeant my first first sergeant
sergeant chuck hawley
i don't think that anybody ever forgets
the name of their first first heart not
officers
and
he brought me in he treated me
i was kind of embarrassed because he had
all these medals and here i am brand new
second lieutenant
no combat experience and he treated me
like
with great respect
and uh
he welcomed me aboard
i mean i never forget the first time i
walked in the orderly room he calls the
oily room to attention i was sort of
baffled you know here i am second
lieutenant you looking over your
shoulder for a kernel yeah what in the
world is going on
but uh yeah and i learned a lot from
sergeant hawley uh my first first
sergeant uh
never forget uh going out on a just a
maneuver
and uh here i am
we we have our military with military
intelligence and my bars military
intelligence battalion air
reconnaissance
my actual unit and i was command of
alpha detachment we had a live mission
we would take photographs that were
taken by the air force sent back to fort
bragg for photographs over vietnam sent
back to fort bragg
and my guys and outfit detachment and
there was bravid attachment charlie
attachment but the mission is given to
our guys we were actually
taking
the photographs and pulling intelligence
out of the photographs using stereo
scopes which you can measure the height
of various objects and so on and so
forth then we would pull all that
together
and we would get
in a bird dog
at uh at fort bragg and fly that to dc
and that and it was a real live mission
i mean how many people can say that you
know they were we were actually doing a
real live mission in support of vietnam
at that time here i was a little second
lieutenant you know barely dry behind
the ears
and uh my first sergeant kept me
straight i had a bunch of warrant
officers work for me too and they really
did all the work um i was there just to
sign my name and
and uh and thank my first sergeant for
keeping me straight how long did you do
that job for four months orders came
down sending me to
flight school at fort walters texas
so you show up to flight school uh when
we were talking when i was talking to
colonel jackson
it sounded crazy the number of
helicopter pilots that were being
trained at that time
it was amazing totally amazing you see
uh matt jackson started off as warrant
officer
so he had a whole different experience
than i did
that was for warren officer candidate
school we called them walks
and people said well what's a walk and
we'd say well that's something you throw
out a wabbit
well i think i think it's funny because
when he when he's talking about uh you
guys the commissioned officers they
called them rlos real life officers yeah
yeah yeah so we had the real life
officers yeah and the walks yeah yeah
the real live officers
yeah and um
and we were all
each class had a designated color uh and
the uh my class had to be the yellow hat
class and you tell different classes by
the color of baseball cap that you wore
and you had these funny wings
that you sewed on
on the front of your hat
they weren't aviator wings but like
student aviator wings and
so
we had the yellow hats the walk class
going through they were yellow hat class
but we never
never got together
and that was um that was the primary
flight training and that's where we just
learned to fly uh my first helicopter
that i climbed into was a
training helicopter 55 it's a huge 300
aircraft but it was small i mean you
could probably get the whole aircraft
into this room would have to probably
knock out part of your wall so the tail
rode it would get it through but that's
how small it was i mean it was smaller
than the oh-13 and most people remember
that by when they watched mash
or the h-23 which was
back in that era as well but that's what
i learned to fly on it was so tiny and
being tiny it wasn't easy to fly it was
very squirrely
so um i remember people i said man i
wish i was in that 13 or that 23 and
they said well you know you're getting
some great polish skills in in that th
55 because you're learning how to adjust
for wind and so on and so forth and they
said boy when you get to when you get to
rucker that huey is going to be like
you're climbing out a little fiat into a
rolls royce
and uh i remember our first
cross country after we had soloed
i soloed at my 14th hour you had to solo
within 16 hours or you got sent back to
another class
so i soloed in my 14th hour
and that's amazing getting you know the
instructor pilot gets out and says okay
you've got the aircraft and yeah you fly
the idiot circle and you call takeoff
you call
turning uh into the wind you call based
and you call final you had to do all the
correct call signs and everything and we
were at little staging areas all around
fort walters texas which was in mineral
wells texas
so
we probably had staging areas as much as
50 miles out because you had all these
classes and all these various staging
areas
um and uh i'll never forget it was a
little anxious when he climbed out of
that cockpit and i knew that i was in
control
and uh
but then after you flew your first solo
coming back in the bus didn't stop it
fort walters at the at the fort it
stopped at the holiday inn
tradition is
everyone who soloed the bus would stop
there
and those who hadn't soloed yet stayed
on the bus those who had already soloed
got off the bus with the new solo guys
and they carried you and threw you in
the pool
at the holiday inn and interestingly at
the holiday inn in
in
mineral wells they had crossed huey
rotor blades that you walked under to go
to the swimming pool
and uh to have that honor of being
thrown in the pool
was just incredibly amazing and
fulfilling
did you have any did you have any
trouble when you were going through
aviation school did it come pretty
naturally to you
were you you know did it did you did you
figure it out pretty quick or when you
said 14 hours was that
well no i mean we had some guys that uh
that soloed at 10 hours
i mean they were i mean just incredible
but you have to understand a lot of the
guys i went through with already had
their private ticket
most of my fixed-wing i don't know of
anyone in my class that had a rotary
wing private ticket uh
and had they done that they could have
probably so loaded in five hours you
know it just all depends but um
leaving there
well here's the other interesting thing
all the pilots we're getting this flight
pay plus we're getting our our normal
second lieutenant pay which i think was
like 247 dollars a month how much was
flight pay oh flop pay was kind of
i know when i quit getting flight pay at
the end it was like 400 something
dollars a month but so that's kind of
crazy right like you're almost doubling
your pay oh yeah oh yeah and but but the
interesting thing about it is you got
all these single guys here so what do we
do we go to the to the car dealer
so everybody i remember uh
a good buddy of mine was my roommate uh
uh he and i actually lived in a motel
right up beside the gate of fort walters
and he had a
camaro
z1 z28 whatever it was
zcarp d28 i had the osmo bill 442
and
i mean that just goes on all the hot
cars you know the single pilot you know
we thought our sierra didn't stink
we had that stuff you know we
you know we were just uh
there there was something about that
that just started the camaraderie just
started building and i remember when we
left
um
fort walters to go to fort rocker
alabama for our pr uh our advanced
training
uh there were four of us that that
convoyed
uh all the way to uh and we made our
first pit stop in uh montgomery alabama
but we convoyed all the way down through
there and we all had cbs in our cars so
you know it was like we were flying and
we were talking to each other and that
and and on the back of the car we uh
everybody had
united states army aviation
and a little sticker in the back of your
window you know and
you know like i say we thought our
sierra didn't stink
and uh we got to
we got to montgomery we all checked in
that night
and uh
i got a call from the desk that said uh
uh i've got you listed as owning a
a 1968 osmo bill 442
it's a black vinyl top with blue bottom
i said yeah
yeah that's
that's mine
he said sir you need to come to the desk
so i go to the desk
and there's a truck driver there he had
pulled his
18-wheeler into the parking lot of the
motel where the four of us were all
staying
didn't cut sharp enough and hit the left
rear
quarter panel of my car
and tore all the pieces
i mean
schneider trucking i'll never forget
this you see there are trucks on the
road all the time and i'll forget the
stock oh and he was so apologetic and so
on and called his dispatcher and
everything was fine
but uh
anyhow
we had a couple days before we had to
report into uh
to uh
fort rucker
so my plan was i was just gonna drive
the car up to north carolina
give it to my dad they get it fixed up
he'd give me his car i'd drive it down
to to rucker
well
we get up the next morning and i get a
call from my roommate that had been my
roommate
in
in the primary training and he said hey
goomba his name was john vagneti
hey goomba
uh okay now that the joke's up i said
what are you talking about john
where's my car
i said john
i don't have your car oh come on come on
somebody had stolen his car that night
now my car gets hit somebody steals
john's car that night montgomery police
does all the
all the investigation
and
so the next so after that was done i
said okay throw your guarantor we're
driving at north carolina so we drove to
north carolina
picked up my dad's car
in the meantime john calls his
dad uh who owned a company called
superior plastics and uh
in uh water uh
i'll think of in a minute but in new
jersey
and uh anyhow john has a new car waiting
for him
just like that from that
but uh
yeah that was uh that was the beginning
of our uh our
uh advanced course in flying helicopters
for the united states army so when you
get to wreck uh fort rucker is that when
you start flying the huey yeah yeah yep
it was and it was like everybody said uh
the huey came natural to me uh it was
just i mean it was amazing to
crank that thing up and uh
and then to
hold the cyclic and pull up on that
collective and that i mean it was just
it's like everybody said it's like going
from a fiat into a rolls royce and it
was so
easy i mean it was you know even though
it had a little crosswind it wasn't it
wasn't shifting like the th-55 did
i mean the th-55 would shift if you had
a three-knot crosswind
so uh
but it was an incredible incredible
aircraft
and
of course while we were flying that we
were also getting our instrument
training down there that's the first
time we'd been on instruments so the
instrument training was not in the huey
it was in
an oh 13
and that's where we were under the hood
and and uh flying on instruments and uh
and got what we called attack ticket
tactical ticket it wasn't the regular
standard instrument ticket that one
would normally get uh but was a tack
ticket and what was interesting about
that and this will come up later in our
conversation is i learned how to shoot
ground control approaches very well gca
approaches very well we'll talk about
that later on in our conversation is
that where you learned originally to
shoot it
that's where i learned to shoot it yep
and it came in very handy in vietnam
so how much longer was it until you uh
how long was that training
um that training we got there and uh so
that had been about uh
i must have been about three
three or so months because i think in
july yeah it was in july that uh
that i got my several wings pinned on me
and
my mom and dad drove down
uh it was a wonderful experience my
girlfriend at the time came down with my
parents
i was so proud of those wings i mean
i was so proud of being a butter bar in
december 67 and so proud of of getting
those wings
later on
that would have been in 69
because
you know 68 i took over the command and
went to flight school went through
christmas graduated in july of 69
very proud of that i remember
every weekend while we were at fort
rucker
a bunch of us
would go to panama city florida and
there was a young couple and their two
children owned a motel there
so we went down negotiated with them
that
we would like to come down every weekend
and stay in the same suite of rooms
uh
and they knew that we were everybody in
flight school was on orders to go to
vietnam right out of flight school and
and they were certainly aware of that
and so they took us up uh on our offer
that we would arrive on friday night and
leave on sunday
and
she had a a closet
in the suite and she said you just keep
all your beach clothes everything down
here uh i'll wash them i'll clean them
up for you and i'll hang them back up in
the suite and she did that every night
every friday night we got down there
she and her family had dinner prepared
for the four of us and we all eat
together as a family
now that's
that's people who cared absolutely and
um
i took my parents there and uh
right after we drove down to panama city
after i got the silver wings and we
stayed in that hotel that night and uh
with them and
and uh
we all congregated the family that owned
it we all congregated together and uh
then i left out the next day my parents
stayed down on florida for a while
uh
but the next day was the landing on the
moon
and we washed it after my girlfriend and
i watched after we got back
uh into hickory uh from driving from
panama city florida
now one of the things that i when i
first covered um
uh
colonel jackson's first book you know
one of the one of the statistics that he
brings up in the book is
there was 5 000 huey sent to vietnam and
3 200 of them were lost in combat
did your parents know these kind of
statistics were they nervous as hell
were they talking to you about you know
what was going to happen how did you
feel about it um
my parents
i never expressed any worry whatsoever
about being in fact i wanted to go to
nom
right after flight school
there were too many infantry officers
serving infantry aviators in vietnam
there were not enough slots for all the
after aviators there were entry aviators
who were like i'm third in line to be a
platoon leader
as a captain
so what happened
was all the infantry officers in my
flight class out of rucker
their orders were changed from vietnam
to state side assignments
so i went to fort bragg and flew with
alpha company 82nd aviation battalion
there i flew with seasoned aviators who
had come back from vietnam
i was a platoon exo my platoon leader
was captain fred dickens who had flown
with the little bears in the 25th
emperor division
he had flown over into cambodia during
that incursion a lot of that's written
cambodia has written up in matt's first
book there
but i learned a lot from fred i learned
a lot
from the other
a lot of the war officers that were
there
who just
jim foster for example um
he had flown with the 48th blue stars
and
learned a lot about him because we did a
lot of tactical maneuvers with the 82nd
during that time and
he sort of gave me a feel for what i
would be doing when i got to nam
um
jim ended up being a roommate with uh
myself and uh fred dickens captain
dickens um gemini stayed friends
until this day he was going to get out
of the army and i talked to him into
staying in the army
and encouraged him to
to extend his enlistment as warrant
officer which he did and finally retired
out of the army i hope sometime jim can
hear this podcast and
and can smile a little bit about that
what's very interesting is is that
after i
i put in my orders to go
to nom again
requested none orders came down sending
me to the seventh ifter division in
korea
commanding the seventh after division
was a god by the name of hal moore who
was lieutenant colonel helmore in the
eye drang valley with the first calf and
we all know about we were soldiers once
and young
general moore at that time was two-star
general
and i was the seventh aviation battalion
maintenance officer
and when general moore was a rated
aviator he had to fly four months or
four hours every month to maintain
proficiency draw flight pay
i don't know if you tell a general
officer you can't draw flight pay but at
any rate uh
my job was to fly co-pilot with him and
i got to know him
and uh so this is this in korea this is
in korea now see i've put in orders i
put in a request to go to vietnam
down
sending me to korea okay okay
so
i
was not that much aware of general moore
i didn't know about the idrang valley
back then i mean this was in 71. i
didn't know much about the i drank
valley not 71 i'm sorry this was in uh
when i got to korea from bragg
and
so
he asked me one day while we were flying
how i liked my assignment with the
seventh and i told him well it was fine
but i said if i don't get to vietnam sir
i can kiss my career goodbye because i
mean you know i want to be a career army
officer and if i don't have vietnam time
and have
performed well in nam i'll never be a
career army officer
and he talked a little bit he said would
you have a particular unit you want to
go to and i said yes sir i'd like to go
to the 25th entry division
a flaw with the aviation battalion he
says
any particular company i said alpha
company sir they're known as the little
bears he said i know the little bears
i've heard of the little bears they're a
great unit
that was on saturday
on monday i got a call from the
general's aide
and it said uh
general wants to make sure you're ready
to go to nam i said yes i am
okay you want to go to alpha company
25th aviation battalion oh the journal
wanted to know if you want to take any
leave in the states i mean he can only
authorize 20 days but
i said well sure if i get that
within
three or four days orders came down now
i've been in korea now
maybe four or five months by that time
orders came down and on usually orders
and probably the same thing in the navy
you have
you have regulations that authorize just
and such there were no regulations
authorizing anything on my orders it was
all
voco which means voice command voco
between commander 17 for division
commander 25th infrared division
uh voco and it went all the way down to
even commander of the airlift in out of
oakland
and
my leave my 20 days leave started and so
anyhow i go to kenpo airport i get on
the airplane
okay i'll fly home my 20 days didn't
start until i reached my home of record
and the 20 days was up the day that i
left my home of record so i'm
on not on leave until i reach my point i
left there after 20 days
flew to oakland
then oakland to nam
i get to nam
and this was in the fall of
70. i get to numb we're all getting off
the airplane you know everybody hears
about the humidity how it just kills
sucks the air out of you when you get
off the airplane uh landing at tonsino
so get off the airplane okay there's a i
think a lieutenant a major lieutenant
colonel out there and a bunch of
enlisted men
and they say okay all the officers over
to my right okay and then the sergeant
major said okay all the ncos in front of
me and there's another e7 that says okay
i'll list them in down here on this side
so we all get over there okay they're
calling out names so
the colonel the colonel major is calling
out all the officers names
says is there any name that i haven't
everybody's raising their hand said any
name i haven't called out i said here i
am he said you must be captain tate i
said well yes sir i am he said well your
charp will be here in 20 minutes geez
and a chopper flew in
from the 25th from alpha company 25th
aviation battalion to pick me up
oh mackerel
so pick me up
take me to coochie where the 25th
headquarters is
we get out of here you must have made a
hell of a good impression generally
a jeep picks me up drives me to the
orderly room
and i
i go in and salute to the company to
come in no matter who's a major majors
command at companies uh uh and nom
and uh
the major said
i don't know who the hell you are but
welcome aboard
shut my
excuse shook my hand
and uh
that was my introduction to the alpha
company 25th aviation
that's amazing
yeah you know you you made a joke about
hey i don't know if you can
if you need to uh take the the flight
pay away from a general officer
apparently those general officers had
some power
that's incredible general hal moore um
and i've read the book i've watched the
movie quite a few times uh
even general moore before he passed away
thought that mel gibson did a good job
representing him and and the sergeant
major
um
but uh
you know that was a he was a hell of a
man a great leader uh he was um
he was not one of these uh general
officers that set himself up on a
plateau he was down with his troops
and uh
and i saw that quality in him
and
i was
in great admiration
for that
so you show up
so you show up uh what what's the first
thing that happens when you show up in
vietnam now they they what did they they
must have thought you were the best
pilot or something unless i thought you
were somebody
the uh
company xo
company commander says
exo get captain tata place to stay
the echo
exo said uh well sir where would you
like to stay
and uh i said well my buddy fred dickens
captain dickens he stayed in a hooch
called the holiday inn
he said is that still around he said oh
yes sir hall dan's right over here he
said let me say oh yeah there's a bunk
available so i stayed in the same hooch
that captain dickens
stayed in and uh after i got everything
squared away uh
uh the exit said uh now they're gonna be
cocktails up here at uh captain
so-and-so's place and he showed me where
there was he said
he said so come on up and meet the guys
well this captain was great at fixing
martinis
so
hecky i went up there
had a martini they had some hors
d'oeuvres out there and i thought wow
this is vietnam so this is this is
really crazy
so
uh i was with them
right at two months
into the first of november
and um
orders came down for the 25th to draw
down
uh and prepare to head back to hawaii
and i thought to myself man this is
really great i've been here two months
now i'm going hawaii
and uh i'd already been laying out on
top of a bunker in a lounge chair i had
a nice suntan and
and
of course my dermatologist doesn't think
it's a nice suntan today but at any rate
uh
i thought wow this is gonna be i said
i'll get to hawaii i'll you know i'll
already have my tan everything look good
well
uh no
everyone who had
less than six months in country got
reassigned
so
i found my young rear
on a c-130 several about a week or so
later headed to a core
there was no everything was pacified in
three core where the 25th was i never
flew into one hot lz in fact i never
flew into an lz in three core that had
all been pacified
so i mean i had i never even heard the
door gunners work out uh with the 25th
because there was there was no enemy
threat
we thought at least that time it wasn't
apparent
get on the c-130
uh fly me up to uh fubai fubai
international
uh i-corps
uh very close to the uh
to the north-south vietnamese border
uh got off the aircraft
uh got my parachute packing bag with me
full of my
stuff
pouring down ring
and
uh they'll load us into a building and
say we were going to go to screaming
eagles uh uh
orientation training
and uh we did that for
about a week and then it got reassigned
to my regular unit
now interesting i was with alpha company
82nd aviation battalion
when i got to the 7th i was actually
assigned
as a staff maintenance officer but i was
located in alpha company 7th aviation
battalion
25th i go to alpha company 25th
where did i get assigned 101st aviation
battalion alpha company 101st aviation
battalion known as the commentary flight
that was a week after i had become a
101st
air assault
trooper
then how long was it before you started
flying missions with them
took my check ride the next day
uh i was a peter pilot the following day
went into a hot lz first time i'd ever
heard the m60 machine gun
door gunner and crew chief working out
the ship literally danced when they
pulled that trigger uh you could feel
the shake going in
and going out hot lc i heard
three pings on the aircraft came back
and i i experienced what they call you
got your cherry busted
we took three rounds in the aircraft
going that lz
uh came back that night once you got
your cherry busted in the unit a lot of
spree decor i mean
there's a spirit of core like you would
well you would because you've
experienced
that jocko but
but but i hadn't experienced anything
like that and uh
so what do we do he had to get initiated
before you could wear the unit patch and
we had to drink this drink called a
flamin hooker
sounds tasty
it was
southern comfort
uh and you take a match and you light it
so you got the blue flames coming up
and uh
echoes laughing here like he knows
and had to drink it down
all the way down set the glass down
while the blue flame is still burning
inside of it then turn it upside down
and if more than two flaming drops
came out of that glass you had to drink
another one until you got it down
now keep in mind i was an rlo a real
live officer
all of the warren officers
they had a spirit of core like you
you've heard of the war officer
protective association wapa
they took care of each other well they
all most of them had
mustaches
can you imagine drinking that flamin
hooker and you've got a mustache and
that blue flame is coming up and uh
there there were quite a few times that
the the mustaches had to be put out and
of course the bartender was there with a
glass of water that he could throw
over in our little officers club i was i
was on a little assignment overseas and
and we were in a bar and they had a they
had like a executive
happy hour
from
you know four till six
so we'd show up there at 3 59 and it was
free it was free drinks
free drinks for two hours and i had like
half a platoon with me
so we're in there and this is when i was
a young enlisted guy was crazy
and so we drink for the two hours
and then we get done and now obviously
everyone's primed but i remember telling
the bartender
uh we actually yeah we
we had run up quite the tab and i looked
at the bartender i said we don't want to
drink anything else unless it's on fire
so every drink sport is lighting
everything off it was total total mayhem
uh
you know we all got to k we all couldn't
wait till a new guy came in to the
outfit and and that was in the oak club
hey the enlisted guys god knows what was
going on
they were sadistic
but but we couldn't wait till a new guy
came in
you know one of the things that colonel
jackson talked about and wrote about was
uh you know some of the flying that
you're doing when you're when you're uh
formation flying flying and how it's so
much closer than it was back in the
states and then the the whole thing with
the hover holes and getting down in
there and having to listen to your crews
like a hundred percent you can't see
actually what they're telling you you
just have to trust them did you were you
up to speed on that stuff or did you
have to just get the steep learning
curve
learn formation flying at fort rucker
for fort rucker when i left fort rucker
i was confident i could fly that
airplane i knew i could fly that thing
and um and we uh
uh right where the jesus nut is on a on
a huey which holds the main rotor in uh
there's like a red rubber gasket so what
you would do is you would for the
helicopter let's say we're flying
echelon left
all the helicopters from the lead are
going to the left to fly formation in
that you would come up and you would
have you would put the red rubber uh
grommet right on uh
right about just below the windshield
just
at the lower end of the so that would
keep your height above it so you
wouldn't get caught up in a rotor wash
from the other helicopter but you would
keep it up and in a in a
staggered echelon left uh you've got the
lead but every other helicopter is a
little bit higher than the ones in in
front of them
and we flew a lot of formation flying uh
at rucker so i felt very comfortable
with that um and and then like i said i
was very fortunate to go to the 82nd
after uh infantry's after flight school
uh instead of going straight to nine
because i i became
even more proficient that more
proficient in in
in formation of flying
but there's one thing you learn in
formation flying
in nom
is you don't want to get too damn close
because
one round can take out two
especially if it's 23 mike mike or 37
and uh
and uh you don't be flying through
debris
i mean you know so you did um
and and we'll get talking about lamsan
719 uh we did 20 second separations in
in that
how long were you how long were you then
with 101st before lamson went down
okay um
so i got to i got 101st
uh got into my unit a week before
thanksgiving of 70.
um
quick side story uh my cousin charlie
finger was with the 501st signal
battalion ballistic guy
on his second tour volunteered for his
second tour
um
i got a hold of charlie
brought him over to uh our unit took in
the officers club
we had thanksgiving dinner to the other
uh now think about that you're with your
family having thanksgiving dinner
together november 1970
and uh
uh it was just a wonderful day to see
charlie uh i never saw charlie after
that uh he derosed uh went home
uh
i said i i told him i said um charlie
i'll come over uh what not grab you and
uh you can be my guest at uh at
um
the art the artillery uh uh battalion
there because they always had the good
shows the uso shows and the korean shows
with all the all-girl korean bands i
said i'll come over and get you one
night he's and he said sir uh
i said charlie i'm your cousin he said
sir it wouldn't be safe for you as an
officer to be around our barracks at
night
and uh you know fragging was a thing
over there and uh
it was uh so i took him to that and uh
all right so make a long story short um
i'm flying combat missions i flew my
first command and control sog missions
probably by in december
because they just didn't let anybody fly
at the command and control
north missions
you had a chance to have three r r's or
you have two r rs if one of your r and
r's you want to go back to the states
so i like to go back to the states a
week after a week after uh christmas
and uh
went back spent a wonderful time with my
family
uh new year's eve there uh with fred
dickens uh he and uh by the time his
wife uh my
ceo for captain fred
and uh
i left about a week after uh after that
to fly back to uh vietnam
got into uh
tons of newt
and uh
tried to get a went to flight operation
i said i need to get up to uh fubai and
the guy said sir there's there's a major
major operation a big thing going on he
said i don't know when i can get you out
of here i said i got to get out of here
quick if there's a major thing going on
i said he said well sir just stick
around here and lo and behold within an
hour uh they had a uh
c123
flying that that's
130 and one there's a big difference
between those two aircraft but you'd
rather fly on a 130. anyhow c123 is only
two engines
so
when you were flying those um when you
flew sog missions i mean i look at the
profile those sog missions that those
guys were doing
and it just it's
it seems just completely crazy were you
thinking that were you thinking okay
here's whatever two americans and four
vietnamese soldiers i'm going to drop
them off in the middle of cambodia or
laos and
and we'll see what happens did that seem
crazy to you
you know it didn't it didn't
right on and and i'll tell you what man
we would fly down to uh da nang
uh well we flew out of three lo with sag
denying was the major base that was
their headquarters there was one at fuba
and there was one at country dongha area
the ones we flew out of uh denying
were
crazy i mean it was i mean it's like
they got the music going everything
and uh and would flight follow with
covey the air force fixed wing who would
be up above us and and uh vector us into
where we're supposed to go uh
i don't know
how much of this i can
i guess it's pretty declassified by now
yeah well i mean it's pretty
declassified it's been 20 years was the
time level so uh
here's here's a mission we're going to
we fly team in uh
yeah we put them in an area where covey
has uh
either told us or shot white white
phosphorus down and landed and then we
we
sparrow and go down into the landing
zone
uh spiral and go into the landing zone
we drop them off
uh
then if they get into contact
uh then we gotta go back in there and
pull them out which that did happen uh
quite a few times a lot of times it
didn't happen it didn't happen at all uh
there were times we went in uh and they
were in contact we had to pull them out
with ropes mcguire rigs 120 foot ropes
stretched 10 feet 130 foot they had to
strap them on we had to pull them out of
the had the jungle sometimes it was
ladders that we would drop down and
they'd climb up on the ladders and get
out um
one and that was extractions uh
we never did
well we did some insertions with ropes
too uh because they were going out on
the side of a mountain there were no way
with foliage uh and there was no way we
could land um
so we would we would put them down but i
remember times that i pulled guys out on
ladders and there would be
there were three guys on my ladders now
you got to think about that and the
density altitude and what that does to
lift a helicopter so we got them out and
got them back in
to vietnam
that's when you said oh my god thank god
we're back in vietnam
you know that's when you that's when you
start to realize it and we came in and
we had to land in a like a rice pad he
said these guys could get off the
ladders and get back in our chompers
and you just didn't and any any moment
you just felt like
this is it i'm gonna
i'm gonna buy it
and a couple of our guys did and
uh on
cabana control north missions and uh
died
and uh a lot of the
uh saw guys went with them so that's you
know that's the bad part i lost 14 guys
uh the year i was uh and um
but
here's one mission we flew in we we were
going to insert a team
landed to the lz
big elephant grass
probably eight feet high
a roto wash
lays the grass down and when it did the
whole lz was ringing with the nva
and our door gunner started working out
and firing everybody's firing and
everybody said sorry get the hell out of
here get the hell out of here and we
were firing firing we were taking rounds
too but nobody nobody aboard our
aircraft
was injured
i mean that's just one thing
we would do prisoner raids
intel would tell us where there was a
big nva battalion headquarters
we had we had all the all the intel on
it we knew the comings and goings had
been washed and washed and watched
and
we have a flyout flight of four
the uh the third aircraft was always had
the medic on the fourth aircraft was the
aircraft that would pull your ass out if
you got shot down
first two aircraft
would go in uh i happened to be on the
second aircraft on one of these prisoner
raids where we went in and landed right
in the damn middle of a
nva battalion headquarters the guys on
board jump out i bet you we weren't on
the ground 20 seconds and they're coming
back in they've got captives they've got
uh
all sorts of documents in their hand we
get back on that ship and we're our
asses out of there going to the nine
i mean that's the co and it
it was exciting i mean i'm not going to
tell you if the anxiety wasn't there but
i wasn't scared
it was exciting
and they would come back and have cold
beers yeah
i mean that's sog yeah another day at
sog
so i guess you did think those missions
were a little bit crazy
uh yeah but but it was fun crazy you
know
we were young we didn't know any better
i guess to fly them today
i probably couldn't see the damn
instruments but
uh so you're flying you're flying a
bunch of those missions and and now
you're i mean it sounds like you're
racking up some pretty good hours and
some pretty good um experience at doing
it
and and then
so so lam son when did you so you got
back from your your christmas and new
year's leave so that's january whatever
yes it's early part of january you come
back and now it's um
it's you get told immediately hey
there's some kind of big operation we
don't really know what it does but you
got to get up there um
no they just said there's a big
operation going on in our core and and
they and i said i got to get up there
uh i told them i'm a platoon commander
up there i've got to get out there yeah
my guys uh need me up there stop so
anyhow i get up there um
it's very well
that it's kept quiet
um so when i got into my unit
and said what the hell's going on people
kind of looked at me like
what are you talking about and i told
them all about that
and uh my company commander knew about
it major clue bob clough he's in the
book
uh bob knew about it um
but anyway that's when i told you that
prior and this was in january
uh we take a a sock mission out of uh
ccn mission out of dongha
and we're flying
towards the ocean border uh crossing in
the vicinity a caisson
when
those
red balls of orange balls of fire start
coming up at us and we have to take
evasive action or get shot down
uh by 23 mike mike or 37 i don't
and we knew and and see
as far as as far as i'm concerned
that was reconnaissance in prep four
and that wasn't just one reconnaissance
that was just one of many reconnaissance
and prep four lamson 719.
so the the premise of lam son 719 and
again the the book undaunted valor it's
volume three lambson the subtitles
lampson 719.
the the premise of the operation is that
america wanted to go into
laos and shut down the ho chi minh trail
they also america didn't want to put any
troops any american troops on the ground
inside a laos
because they didn't like the way that
looked politically
so
they decided well we'll run the
operation using south vietnamese
soldiers
but in order to actually execute the
operation they were going to need to
have american aviation because america
was the only one really capable of doing
that job of airlifting all these south
vietnamese soldiers into laos and then
on top of that if you're going to use
the helicopters then we're going to use
the air support too and the air assets
so that that's sort of the premise of
the operation and it's a big operation
the goal like i said the goal is to kind
of put it put a halt on on the portion
of the ho chi minh trail that ran
through the house
and and and the and and and the
headwaters of that was in the town of
sapone
so that was
the final objective
was to capture sappone
it's spelled
t-c-e-p-o-n-e right it's got a weird
spelling yeah it's got a weird string
but yeah
that was the goal that was kind of that
sapone was the furthest away the for the
deepest into laos to get to there would
be correct the furthest north of the ho
chi minh trail
call it the headwaters of the ho chi
minh trail
i would say there's also and and reading
about it there was also
the underlying uh goal was to sort of
prove that the south vietnamese military
could
conduct these operations that they were
capable that they were capable of doing
these kind of things that was part of
nixon's uh
vietnamization
uh policy the more that the south
vietnamese could prove that they could
take care of themselves and defend their
homeland
then the less there was need of u.s
forces especially ground forces
so you're saying that your
your company commander kind of knew
about it when you showed up there i have
to think he did because
major clue did not seem overly surprised
in fact
if i recall and i hope i'm not making
this up but if i recall he seemed
surprised that i made it up in as quick
a time as i did from from saigon
now prior to the actual execution of
lambsson 719
there was another operation that was to
push up to uh to the caisson combat base
yeah off of route nine it's called dewey
canyon too
now did you participate in dewey canyon
too you know i have to think i did but
i'm not it's kind of hard to uh
because i flew so much i mean i flew
over 1200 hours and now i'm 950 of which
were actual combat missions
so i i have to think that i did
i never recall
flying any what they call convoy support
a lot of that would have been done by
charlie model and and cobra gunships
to take action um
no doubt in my mind did i fly supporting
operations for dewey canyon too um but
i never quite tagged it as
as dewey canyon too
uh
hell i had so much going on anyhow of
trying to keep my warm officers enlisted
men and 10 helicopters flying
but the point of
operation dewey canyon too was to was to
push up into
caisson which and get control of it
and then that was going to then be used
as a logistics hub and an air hub to
conduct this big operation
um lambson 719. that's what the purpose
was but in addition to that too was to
uh put the uh
south vietnamese army in a position
to where they could readily launch
uh across the border
so pre-staging all these folks all these
soldiers
and get them ready uh
the
the the area that you were going into
had some serious um enemy troops in
there you know the you know some of the
estimates i read
seven thousand combat troops on the
ground in that area of laos
ten thousand support personnel
um
another another five 000 path of lao
fighters so it was this was you were
going into tough country 33 000 total is
the estimate that's pretty much kicked
around
of all of all the categories you just
described
so when did you when did you actually
find out
that this mission was going down
uh
we got the briefing on it the mission
actually uh
started on 8 february of 71 by that time
101st
command post
was in operation at k-sun
general barry was up there
matt jackson features a lot of barry in
the book
um
and i have some stories about that that
i'll share with you later on
um
i flew several missions
in support of that taking
troops into
uh
hill 30 hill 31
ranger arvind rangers were in 31
we flew we have pickup zones uh uh pz's
if you will
uh at various stages we'd land in and
then take them to the to the lz
uh around there
um but that was just in prep
four
and
really
the big action for me
the thing that
i guess
made me realize that
my god there's a real war going on was
in lz lolo
which was on the 3rd of march
yeah i'll tell you one thing that's
interesting when you read this book and
when you hear about this this operation
you know
most of the time when you think of oh
that what the what the vietnamese are
doing it's sort of like what the north
vietnamese do and what the viet cong are
doing it's sort of like a hit and run it
doesn't seem like these big conventional
operations and if they did do a big
assault on a base you know they'd kind
of do it they'd they'd mess some things
up and then they'd leave
they were doing big coordinated attacks
against the south vietnamese forces it
this was almost like bordering in fact
this was like conventional conventional
warfare correct and uh
but you didn't see that right on eight
february
uh that came later on
and
it was devastating to
to witness some of what i witnessed
after the 3rd of march what i witnessed
on the ground with the south vietnamese
army
especially when we would go into
resupply
around hill 30 and hill 31
i saw some heroism but i saw so many
uh of the arvin army of the south
vietnamese army
uh saw so many of those soldiers throw
the weapons on the ground and run to
grab onto our skids so that when we lift
it off we'd pull them out of the battle
space
that was disheartening it was horrible
yeah i remember reading one one part
where it's exactly what you said a
resupply comes in
and the the helicopters as they leave
they're
overloaded
with arvind soldiers that are just
trying to get out of there throw their
weapons on the ground and run
and grab onto a skid
i mean i witnessed
soldiers losing their grip and falling
fifteen hundred two thousand feet to the
ground below
and
and you say do you feel sorry for them
or do you say
hey you coward you got what's coming to
you
and uh
you know it got to the point jocko where
uh
we would
i remember landing in
and i can't remember i think it was 31
that i landed in uh but we were landing
where mortars were blowing up right in
front of us and we would have to
maneuver over em and mortars were flying
were hitting everywhere in that lc
and
we would literally come to about a ten
foot hover kick off the supplies can't
come into lower because they would jump
on your ship and even at a ten foot
hover they would run jump on people's
back and they would hoof them up onto
the skid
i mean a ten foot hover uh
and uh
and you start to wonder well when's it
gonna be my day
you know
and uh i remember having this uh having
this uh
thing that came through my mind is
uh
you know i know i'm gonna die someone's
not gonna worry about dying i know i'm
gonna die
just don't let me get shot up so bad my
mother can't
recognize me
but i knew i was i was going to get it
i just and then i didn't bother me
anymore it did not bother me anymore
uh
about dying um
i accepted the fact that was going to
happen and you god take care of me
and
a mother would recognize me
having that feeling though and then
seeing the south vietnamese just
you're doing all you can to help them
out risking your lives and they're just
wanting to get out of there
we picked up body bags of the south
vietnamese
body bags for u.s forces and you've seen
them they're sturdy they're zippered the
body bags for the south vietnamese
forces were like one hour martinez and
bags little thin plastic bags had bodies
in them they had laid out in the sun for
for several days they were
all bloated and
body fluids filling up inside the body
bags and
and uh
that's the only time where we really put
skids on the ground so
they could load up bodies
and of course vietnamese didn't run and
jump on the aircraft because they didn't
want to run and jump on
all those bodies that were bloated
and uh it got to the point where we had
to uh where we had to wear gas met one
of us in the cockpit had a gas mask
because of the smell was just nauseating
and uh
we would bring them back into caisson
or lz brown where where a pickup zone
was
and the south vietnamese troops would
unload the bodies and i remember i
remember one it just it just
the guy grabbed the arm of a body and
when he tried to pull the body out the
whole arm came out of the
out of the body
it was just sickening
it was beyond
it was beyond anything that most humans
would ever experience
and
you know you
you go through that and you say well
what's the purpose
why are we why are we here why are we
doing this
i had a warrant officer who i asked
during lamson to ask i said i need more
people to fly this mission
he said i'm not going to fly the mission
i said i need you i'm not going to fly
i said why not he said because nobody
cares congress doesn't care whether i
live or die and what's the use look what
they're doing up there
and i said well mister and i won't say
his name but you got to do what you got
to do
he had too many hours you know he had
over 140 hours flying that month so he
was he was way within his legal rights
to say i'm not going to fly anymore but
guess what most of us had that as well
most of us were flying
i mean dead tired
and we did it and
but you know that started me thinking
who cares who really cares
whether we do whether we do or not
whether we die or whether we come home
alive i mean look at what the south
vietnamese are doing victimization yeah
tell me about it richard nixon why
aren't you over here at lambson 719
looking at this
and then you tell me vietnamization
um
it made me a changed person
and we hadn't even talked about
lz lola
yeah but i mean
lz lolo came a little bit into the
operation i mean i just kind of want to
run through a little bit of the timeline
of
so this this operation starts on
february 8th
that there's
[Music]
4 000 arvin that are going in on on
route 9.
the 39th ranger battalion has heloed
into lz ranger the first entry infantry
divisions going into lz blue and don and
white and brown yeah and and fsb's hotel
delta and delta one and again the the
book gives such good detail on all sides
the planning what the how the decisions
were being made it's just it's just a
fantastic
uh uh
recounting of what happened
um
and meanwhile it's still vietnam you
still got bad weather you still got low
clouds you got heavy anti-aircraft fire
the there's a lot of air strikes are
happening
so
you know the the b-52s are dropping
bombs um
arc lights
yeah the
but look there's a lot of a lot of nva
up there and they're they're ready to
fight
then they start actually um attacking
like i said like th like by
by i don't know february 16th 17th the
the
the nva starts doing organized attacks
correct and um
really bringing it to
to the to the
people to the to the south vietnamese
soldiers that are now on the ground
um
and here's here's another thing that i
was reading about um
by february 24th
there there were reports coming back
that the that the
north vietnamese had completed a new
route and they were just going around
that area of the ho chi minh trail
they were just you know okay well you
guys want to block that cool we'll just
we had another alternate route
um
february 25th just a massive uh uh north
vietnamese assault
and it's combined arms they got armor
they got artillery they got infantry
assault they're doing combined arms
assaults
again this is not what we typically
think of in vietnam i know it happened
from time to time but
it's not what you generally think of in
vietnam you don't think of pitched
conventional warfare like we're dealing
with here
um
there's
just uh yeah yeah the the one quote i
got was
94 there's a helicopter resupply to fsb
and 94 south vietnamese soldiers forced
their way onto the helicopters to get
out of there including the commander
that's on march 2nd by the way
uh
we get to march 3rd which which you've
um
discussed a few times and
and
well actually
let me jump into this um
small small portion of the book here
that that talks about
some of what you guys were doing
i'm going to go to the book here
warrant officer doug womack rattler 2-8
and chalk 3 considered aborting his
approach
watching arnie being shot down and
hearing flight lead calling for mission
abort
not hearing anything else about aborting
the mission he decided he needed to
insert his load of arvind soldiers
unbeknownst to him was the fact that no
arvin
had survived in the first two aircraft
approaching the landing zone he was
subjected to the same intense fire as
the chalks before him upon landing an
rpg rocket was fired but slammed into a
stump and exploded showering the
aircraft with shrapnel when it did time
stood still for mr womack as it seemed
he could count the main rotor passing in
front of the aircraft
several rounds ripped across the
aircraft from three bursts of ak-47 fire
the rotor blades cabin lower fuselage
and skids all received the damage
as the aircraft lifted out of the
landing zone hammer blows were felt by
the pilot look
and the pilot looked back
not only were there holes in the floor
of the cargo area but strange sounds
told him that the main rotor might have
taken some hits as well chalk 4 followed
chalk 3 into the landing zone where it
received intense small arms fire crashed
and burned
chalk four crew scrambled back to choc
five and rode out
this kept up as each chalk came into the
landing zone to drop off the arvin
soldiers on board
choc 16
comment commentero
3-0 flown by bob morris entered the
cauldron of fire and landed
like everyone before him he could feel
and hear the hits on his aircraft
we're on fire someone said over the road
radio but didn't identify themselves
morris pulled in power and initiated his
takeoff
very calmly he heard his crew chief say
over the intercom uh mr morris
you do know we're on fire don't you
mr morris quickly returned to the
landing zone and exited the aircraft
chalk 18 approached the landing zone at
90 knots air speed instead of the usual
40 knots went so close he picked out his
landing point just as a mortar round
exploded at that spot
suddenly his tail dropped low and the
nose went high as captain tate went into
a hard deceleration with numerous hammer
taps on the aircraft
three feet from his touchdown point
there was a loud explosion explosion a
gaping hole appeared in the window frame
and there was the smell of hot metal
engine oil pressure was no longer steady
but fluctuating arvind soldiers had no
desire to wait for him to land and dove
out of the aircraft the safety of a
prone position on the ground
pulling in and pulling in an armpit of
collective tate's aircraft tail number
zero four nine raced out of the landing
zone with a hail of small arms bullets
chafe chasing after him
his aircraft had flown its last mission
within an hour only 19 of the 40
aircraft were able to enter the landing
zone
19 out of 40 aircraft were able to enter
the landing zone
morrison crashed in the landing zone
came back in crashed we had another
aircraft went in berg
flummed by berg he crashed in the lc
they were on the ground
one of the co-pilots
captain uh
jerry crews uh commentario
been a secretary of vietnam first
tour as a ranger
jerry was on the ground with brick 25
radio
calling in airstrikes and actually
conducting the ground warfare in the lz
because the arvind officer uh
major just
jerry knew what he was doing
uh jerry was the one that eventually
said we got to halt this
because there's too much crap going on
in here
and uh kirk lotter uh
obviously took took it and we
stopped stopped the insertion for a
while went back and picked it back up
again later on the afternoon
uh that morning i um
we got hit by a rocket propelled grenade
as as you've described the gaping hole
in the windshield hit the windshield
strut it was
shot at about a 45 degree angle so when
it hit the windshield exploded out
instead of exploding in um crew chiefs
said sir sir sir
get the ass out of here get the ass out
of here sir
the enunciator panel which is all our
control warning lights look like a
christmas tree lit up
and we took off
within within several seconds we started
feeling uh harshness in the controls
um
the hydraulic system warning light was
blinking
and within
within another short amount of time we
lost all hydraulics it took both of us
on the controls to uh it's like going
down the highway at 85 miles an hour and
the power steering goes out
and you're coming up on some major
curves
it took us both on the controls
um
we're finally able to get it back in
called emergency at k-sun
we were like number two or three
emergency at that time
guys ahead of us who had
gotten blown up on lolo
and uh
we got it down we uh
we had to make a low slow and uh and we
thought god we're gonna get shot out of
the sky just trying to get in the land
at uh on the pier still planking runway
at khaesan
but my god it was a
textbook landing
uh and we were able to get her down and
and uh
no sooner then we got it down and asked
the aircraft to do some half of the
chain pull pull the aircraft right off
the roth runway getting ready for
another
another person calling emergency
i remember
colonel fernandez bobby fenander he was
our uh battalion commander 101st
aviation battalion which was part of the
101st aviation group commanded by
colonel davis you'll see davis's name in
that book fernando is also mentioned in
that book but fernando comes out
and sort of throws his arms around us
like god i'm so glad you guys made it
and he said come on there's another
briefing going on in the tent so
we all round over to the big briefing
tent
and uh and your aircraft was is is it
the correct word totaled
yeah it couldn't be flown again it
couldn't be flown again yeah yeah now
whether they
hooked it out of there and got it
repaired or what but it shot out
hydraulics we had 47 holes in that
aircraft that morning we counted the
holes in the aircraft 47 holes and lost
hydraulics and
the
any of you guys any of your guys get
wounded in the aircraft
and that amazing
isn't that amazing
i mean it just it it just blows my mind
but fenner uh came out and i thought it
was interesting here's a lieutenant
colonel coming out and it's like
welcoming us home and hurry up we got to
get a brief intent we got this thing
and we had a briefing tip for the uh we
were in the briefing tent kirk lotter
all were kirklarv's commander 223rd
uh
aviation uh battalion
and uh
he told us about the afternoon mission
we got to get back in there we got more
troops to insert into lolo
and uh
current financial looked at me and he
said well i'm sure you want to go in
there and fly two of your two-year crews
were on the ground in there i said yes
sir i certainly do but i don't have an
aircraft he said would take mine
i said sir he said take mine but the
only thing you got to take my crew chief
with you
and uh and then he pulled me aside and
he said now listen that's a brand new
aircraft don't you bring that thing back
the way you brought yours back this
morning i said yes sir
well you didn't obey that order very
well did you
no because i 58 holes in his aircraft
when we got back that afternoon we were
able to rescue the guys off the ground
so talk us through that so so you launch
again to go back into this is by the way
this is lz lolo you call it lulu low low
low low yeah therefore uh
lo uh
lola brigida they were all named after
liz was after elizabeth taylor uh what
was the other one
i can't think of a name right now uh but
they were all named after hollywood
starlets
but uh
so you know
you get the briefing of okay we got guys
on the ground we gotta go back in there
yeah and you just have 47 holes in your
aircraft when you saw a bunch of your
friends get shot down you saw a bunch of
other aircraft get shot down that are
sitting in the lz now you get brought in
the briefing room hey you gotta go again
you say i don't have an aircraft
aircraft the boss says you can take mine
brett didn't even have 25 hours
brand new huey
and the only one caviar you got to take
my crew chief okay
uh
so
we get to start uh
we get to see okay let's let's crank
them oh and by the way uh uh there was
no unit integrity anymore i mean every
we were just all kind of a whole big
unit like this match whoever could
aviation
whoever could go and so uh
we take off
uh we have troops on board
we take off we put put those troops on
the ground
uh
and i'm hovering around for a few
seconds to make sure that our guys have
gotten off they were picked up by common
chairs in front of me but i wanted to
make sure that we had everybody off the
ground and by that time where as you
described the hammer taps on the screen
that were i mean it was just all over
and
it's like i said earlier some people say
what was it like i said uh take your
bare hand and grab a wasp nest full of
wasp
that's what it was like and uh
so
again the same scenario taking all these
hits thank god didn't get hit by an rpg
uh but the enunciator panel
listing all the uh circuit uh if if a
major system goes down or is damaged you
have a little light that flashes on and
on that light it says for example
hydraulics so you know something's
happened to your hydraulic system uh
tail rotor no something's happened to
your tail so
but the one that got me that started
flashing was
main rotor transmission
what does that one mean
what transmission oh the transmission
chain rotary yeah okay so it means what
it says yeah yeah
uh
and uh
we got her back on the ground we're able
to come to the hover we put it down
at caisson
and the main rotor locked
seized turned the chopper almost 270
degrees around from our landing heading
there were actually bail tech reps
up at ksun
looking at damage and what because they
were writing their reports
for
hey this is what we need to improve on
on the newer models of the huey they
were writing their reports the guy told
me he said sir you're very lucky he said
you could have had
that
transmission could have ceased in the
air he said you guys wouldn't be here
and it seized on the ground
a fenander came over
58 holes in it aircraft
and the locked seized transmission
seized
transmission
that that that helicopter obviously
didn't fly again that day
that's two of them
one day
we
like say we'd lost a lot of aircraft
that day and it was getting nighttime
we had this guy that liked to fix this
stuff called commentary stew
and
uh
there were
on queson
there was actually wild onions you could
pull out of the ground
and uh
he had a bunch of guys that collected
that and
they always kept this pot and poured
can't water in this pot and throw those
things then put a bunch of sea rations
in there and stir all that stuff up and
and uh you know anything tastes good
with texas pete on it and
so
so we were all headed a lot of stuff
done and you know we were everybody was
sort of sitting around i think he had
some paper plates or something with him
and
you know you eat with your fingers and
all that stuff and we were all
comfortable together around there
waiting for
uh major clueless
come over and tell us what our you know
next missions were
we'd lost uh we took ten aircraft up
that morning
and uh we lost
well we lost
if if you count 11 aircraft colonel
fernandez bird
we lost seven
we did have one one uh gunner hit
but you know purple heartworm but
superficial
uh but still he got hit you know that's
bad stuff
but uh
we're sitting there uh sort of gathering
around and uh
all of a sudden we see coming towards us
this
figure just
tall and lean
and just
and i and i got the glint of the stars
on his helmet
and as he got closer to us
he just he was the epitome of
spit-shine boots
and it was general sid berry
and he came over and he said uh
i just want to tell you common chairs
what a great job he did today
and uh
he said uh i i don't want to disturb
your child and we said well sir come on
have some childhood he said no that at
your child i grab something to eat up
here but
i just wanted you all to know what a
great job you did today
and uh with that he said
girl fernando i'm gonna release you all
for the night
so we all jumped on the four remaining
aircraft and
came back to camp eagle
there's a section in here in in the book
where um
that gets described a little bit you're
on this flight back to camp eagle
and i'm going to the book here it says
sitting mesmerized on the floor of one
of the hueys was captain jay tate
comenchero26
tate the second flight platoon leader
was deep in thought having lost two
aircraft this day to enemy fire
the flight was at six thousand feet
flying over
uh flying over a cloud overcast with the
sun projecting the aircraft shadow on
the cloud below them
in addition a halo appeared around the
shadow
he was sitting in the doorway behind the
right seat pilot with a set of
headphones that the crew chief had given
him
wondering to himself why he and his crew
had survived this horrendous day he
heard a voice say to him don't worry jay
you're gonna be
okay he looked up to see who was talking
to him
no one was each passenger was lost in
their own thoughts he heard the voice
again don't worry jay
you're going to be okay
just then amazing grace played on the
armed forces vietnam radio network
and there's a footnote here that says
one week later jay received a letter
from his mother
she related a dream she'd had the night
before in which jay's father had told
her
don't worry jay
you are going to be okay
the letter was dated for march
jay still has the letter
touching
yeah that's uh that's an amazing
amazing story
emotional
um
i watched that shadow
we were actually flying between two
layers of clouds
the sun broke through the upper layer
and cast the shadow
and of course the heat of the chopper
the coolness of that altitude it forms
sort of a rainbow effect around that
shadow
and uh
the the crew chief actually didn't lend
me a
set of earphones i had my flight helmet
on and had it plugged in
listening to afvn and because i had been
talking about
he said
there's a major action a major war going
on up in our core and he said
he said there's been a lot of uh
a lot of helicopters uh destroyed and
said i want to play this next song for
these guys
that's when he played amazing grace
and uh
i can tell you as i sit here right now
i heard that voice
and to get that letter
and to hear my mom and to hear her read
her words
that she thought
dad was telling her
don't worry jay's going to be okay
and she woke my dad up and dad said oh
honey you're dreaming
go back to sleep she said no you said
did you tell me jay's gonna be okay he
said honey don't worry you're
don't tell me there's not a god
i mean if
i pretended to be a christian at one
time but i'll tell you what
that afternoon
i became a christian
that's the only way i can say why i
survived and that's not to say those who
died weren't
because i had prayed god i know i'm
going to die just
don't let me get shot up so bad my
mother won't recognize me
and
i came home
uh changed person
when my mother died
the uh she had the same pastor she
passed away in 2010.
she had relayed that story about the
dream to our pastor
and he had made notes about that that
was in his file
and during her celebration of life
service he he talked about that
when you um got done
when you guys flew back to camp eagle
did you
what did you stand down for the night
and then you went back into it
our flat ops guys
we're monitoring everything on our
company frequency
and they had heard all the chaos
and
the horror that was being
dealt to us
and
so of the 10 crew
we all came back on those four ships
because 11 ships if you count colonel
fernandez ship
uh
they were all outside
waiting for us to come in
waving their hats
and we all landed
and they all ran up and everybody was
getting a hug and everybody was
cold beer was on the on the plot line
and uh
and it was just a
big celebration and especially because
we brought help morris and his crew and
berg and his crew
jerry crews we got them off of there
and they were sitting on on the floor
too
plugged in and listened to something
um
that's the camaraderie
and as i told
uh matt jackson i i said uh
aviation crews are different
uh
rank is superfluous
uh everybody is
has a specific mission
crew chief door gunner co-pilot aircraft
commander everybody has a specific
mission
but nobody can do that one mission by
themselves it takes all of us working
together as a team
and i don't care if i'm a captain
and you're a spec four crew chief
i'm no better than you are
and if it wasn't for you i couldn't be
flying this airplane
same with the door gutter
that's a lesson you learn out of it you
learn a lot about team
you learn about personal courage you
learn about
personal responsibility
you'll learn
a certain sense of tenacity
you can't be lazy
you you've their dedication's got to be
there
and that's what i experienced with these
guys in vietnam
every one of them
there was no lacquered
even the guys in the maintenance
uh hangar that didn't fly those missions
with us and many of them would jump in
to fly a mission just to get out there
and do it
but
even to the clerk that wrote the awards
up
there was such a sense of dedication and
camaraderie that i have never
experienced in my entire life since then
never
in my 20 years in uniform and
the 13 years that i was fortunate to
serve as a civilian with the
with the office of the secretary of
defense
nothing nothing will ever compare
to what i experienced
especially in lambson 719
even the command-and-control north
missions
though they were hairy
though they had some
twists and turns i would have never
expected
and and and we lost two crew on and
control north missions uh that's that's
horrible that uh
but nothing compares with lamson 719
and
i think that's that's where the
what we now see is air salt
that's where it was born
it was born there we had to think on our
feet we did things that weren't written
down we had to think on our feet and uh
i mean like coming to the ten foot hover
versus putting your skids on the ground
how do you learn that you learn it from
experience
um
just just things
i guess they're being learned today uh
and more as they teach our assault at
fort campbell today
uh
but my god that was
i went to a reunion at fort campbell
several years back
and the guys are all flying blackhawks
now then
they looked at us like we were war ii
pilots 5b29
with the low tech all this
and they were captivated by the stories
that we could tell
um
you know
if it wasn't for gps i couldn't drive my
car from point a to point b
but up in the air i could shoot a vector
and i could say pop smoke and identify
the smoke and knew exactly where i was
going
uh just things you'll learn
probably one of the awards i'm most
proud of is an army accommodation medal
and i got that from battalion commander
we inserted his soldiers into the
aishawa valley
this was after uh
after 719
and it had been a long day for them
and uh
sun it was start sun was starting to set
and i get a call from
and and i something six like
and i answer the phone he says could you
take a warm warm mission
i said well yes sir sure sure we can i
did call ops because they're expecting
us
he said well
i want to treat my troops to ice cream
and they've got ice cream and bermite
cans
on our log pad back at eagle
i said not a problem sir
and we flew an ice cream mission
in there
and he awarded his troops for their hard
work
and i got an argument for that
i bet you that ice cream tasted good
yeah
and uh
after that i uh went with lantern and lz
many times i'd get out of the cockpit
i always wore spit shine boots i i i was
dressed right dress red in front the
whole time i always wore spit shine
boots but i made her to
my goal i was going to get out of that
damn cockpit
and i'd say okay peter apology got it
co-pilot
and i'd help the troops unload supplies
off the ship
and i i want to thank they appreciated
that
now here's a aviation captain getting
out of the cockpit and he's doing sweat
work
that's what i learned in vietnam
we had a um
and just an unbelievable relationship
with 101st in the battle of ramadi the
the first the 506 was there yep
and
um can't
i could never say enough good things
about
their leadership and the soldiers on the
ground
the fighting that they did
was just uh
amazing amazing courage
and uh
one of my guys mikey monsoor
was killed doing a mission supporting
them and uh
when we got home
we went out and
on their wall where they have the list
of the soldiers that they lost
in the battle armadi they have mikey's
name up there with them
i think we're fortunate jocko
we're fortunate that we knew people like
that
and there will be people who will go to
their graves
that never experience that kind of
heroism that kind of commitment
that kind of courage
that kind of teamwork the camaraderie
they will never
ever experience it
and i think you and i are very fortunate
that we've had that opportunity
indeed
i wouldn't trade it for the world
um
going back to to to lam sawn once you
had that
did they give you a night of rest and
then you started flying missions again
uh
i had
two days down
and then started flying again
it was after that that uh
during the resupplies when i think the
arvin knew that
the nva
had a hell of a lot more confidence in
their ability than the organ did
it was after that during
doing those resupply missions in there
that
that i actually experienced them
abandoning the battle
uh i didn't experience that before
lemson 719.
um
i always thought it was interesting when
we would
we're going to a pz
uh early morning but
put it put the choppers down waiting for
them to load up the arvin the suffering
means to load up
but i'd see them sitting there
and they had water and they're still
pots and they were brushing their teeth
and it was like this is extremely
important that i brushed my teeth and i
always thought
well that's kind of interesting that
they're doing that personal hygiene
and they're going to pour the water out
put their helmet liners back in put
their helmets on they're gonna climb on
board this aircraft and god knows what
faces them when they hit the lz
but they made sure that their teeth were
clean
um
as this goes on like you said the the
tide started to turn and and
uh
i think the goal became just to get to
how did you say it pony is that how they
say it japon chapon the goal is to get
there
they kind of got there like almost like
playing tag touched it yeah we made it
and then said
let's get out of here and by the way
there was hardly anything there by then
um
then and and then as the as the arvin
started to retreat then the nva stepped
up the attacks even more
and it just
slaughtered yeah
and that's where i picked up the body
bags
with the dead arvind soldiers in them
[Music]
turns into a bit of a route
as the as the
arvin are now leaving
you know there's
again i mean i'm just gonna a couple
days here march 21st
the the nva the north vietnamese
attack their division attacks the second
and third battalions u.s air support
during the day included 780
helo gunship sorties
157 tactical airstrikes and 11 b-52
strikes
fast forward another day march
23rd 756 hilo gunship sorties 238
tactical airstrikes 11 b-52 strikes
this is as they're kind of getting back
to the border in to south vietnam right
march 25th finally 45 days after the
start of the operation
all the south vietnamese forces are out
of laos
and
well so to speak yeah yeah stragglers
yeah um
i guess the ones that they are
accounting for yes are back
[Applause]
april 6th
the basic caisson is under attack and
it gets abandoned
and to your point earlier on april 7th
so that's april 6 the the operation
is over caisson is abandoned
april 7th president nixon declares
tonight i can report that via
vietnamization has succeeded
and announces a further withdrawal of
100 000 more troops
friendly losses during this operation
seven fixed wing planes 108 helicopters
lost
618 helicopters damaged 20 beyond repair
32 artillery pieces captured and these
are south vietnamese artillery pieces
south vietnamese tanks 71 of them
south vietnamese armored vehicles 163 of
them 37 half tracks 278 trucks
destroyed south vietnamese lost and i
couldn't
really come up with a great number on
this
but it's between 5 000 and 15 000 men
killed wounded or missing depending on
the source that you go to
americans
149 wounded
38 missing in action
215 killed in action
you know that's the second time we left
caisson
we left it in 68
after the marines got overrun
and here we go again and
you often hear combat soldiers say we
fought hard we lost guys in our unit to
take that hill and after we took it we
left it now we have to go back and take
it again
there it is
when
so now this operation's over
i mean did did
did attitude start to change you're
hearing nixon saying that vietnamization
is working and
you see the you see the south vietnamese
fleeing the battlefield
what was the
what was the attitude of you all
in my unit and that's all i can speak
for
uh
the esprit de accord never never ceased
we were still flying command and control
north supporting those guys
and their mission
grew even
more
critical because they were there judging
okay now that lamsun's over
what
what's the pavon
the north vietnamese army doing now
where are they
you know it was during that time
uh
shortly after i left they overran quan
tri dongha
uh
evans
uh was certainly within their site camp
evans which was uh north of uh camp 100
first headquarters
but i never saw
any sense of uh
behavior that said okay well 7-7-1-9 is
over
i guess the war is over
i never saw that attitude
our soldiers
remain very professional soldiers
that's amazing because many of them were
just 19 years old some armor 18.
i had a warrant officer for 21.
i was an old dude i was 25.
i never
never once
questioned
uh
our our ability
as an aviation unit
to do the job the mission that we were
assigned to do
even after even up until the day
i left when i became the operations
officer my last four months in country i
got a chance to look at at the battle
space in a different way
because i would go to battalion
and battalion ops and look at that then
come back and put that into company ops
and
work our portion of the mission our
company's portion of the battalion
mission
and uh
i'd bring the guys into the briefing
room the guys are going to be flying
that mission
and i'd say okay
this is our objective right here
now how do we get there
we're here
this is our objective our mission is
this we got to put so many troops in
there
how do we get there
and usually it wasn't just one place it
was if it was
a company plus it would be maybe three
different places we'd have to go
and i never would say okay this is how
we're going to do it you're going to do
it i think how do we get there
what what's the best approach
to make this happen and i was the
operating staffs
and i'd have these young award offices
oh let's do this today and somebody said
no no we can't do that we got to do this
somebody said well let's do it this way
well okay well let's take a piece of
that next thing you know
they
had planned the operation
all i did was approve it
but that
that's a leadership skill that i learned
from people like
colonel bobby fernander
who never said you're going to do it
this way
he always sort of facilitated if you
will
facilitative leadership and that's what
you're seeing now in business
facilitative leadership
getting people involved and if the more
you're involved the more you take
ownership
and that's what i saw in our guys
that's what i saw in our guys
during lam son that's what i saw in our
guys after lam sun
now when we were flying command and
control north
we did what they told us
they had a very specific way of doing
things and that's the way we were going
to do it and that's fine
and that's fine
but
this is the way we did it
um
and i mirrored my
leadership style
after people that i had great respect
for
uh
to include general helen moore who
became lieutenant general helmore
uh and the way that
the camaraderie the the so not
camaraderie
i don't want to say i was buddy buddy
but general moore because i was not but
we had a we had a relationship in the
cockpit and i think he respected my
desires what i wanted to do obviously
because i wouldn't have gone to nam
had it not been for that
yeah i don't know if you didn't have a
relationship with hal moore but jesus if
you were friends with him who knows what
he would have done for you
[Laughter]
what a great man he was but but i left i
left vietnam feeling very good about
my unit and about what we did um
i did change my
views
a bit to think that
my tour and nam will be successful
if i can do things to support
my u.s troops
so that changed from supporting the
whole concept of vietnamization
for example if i can bring ice cream out
to those troops after they've busted
their butt all day
inserting
then i've done something that i can be
proud of
and uh
and that's where my mind sort of changed
after being in country for about eight
months
to support my soldiers
and
to do what i could to bring them home
yeah the the leadership stuff you're
talking about that's exactly the the
best leaders i had was they would tell
us what the mission was what the goal
was and then say come up with a plan and
that's what i always tried to do myself
that certainly is the
the best way to get people on board with
the plan is just let them come up with
it that's right you don't have to
convince them of anything
it's their idea it's their plan let them
argue it out yeah yep
so when you did uh so what what when
when did you leave vietnam
it was in october of 71.
and
in nam there was four officers that
lived in the same hooch
we all had our little private
rooms at the corner of this rectangular
hooch then the center was a common area
and we had a little stove in the common
area and so on but
um
right across from me was um an officer
stan dodge
he was coming to a 1-8
and
so when we would fly when i knew he was
flying i'm going to be in the air then
he and i would choose a frequency
uh
that we would come up on just and would
follow with each other in the air so
sort of looking after each other you
know in the air
so
i came back from from knobs it's very
interesting story uh
there was me as a comenchero
and then there were three other pilots
who were kingsmen they were in bravo
company 101st aviation which was our
sister company
and
we all knew each other
and we all came back we were in our
khakis wearing our flight jackets and
you know we thought our sierra didn't
stink
and we get back into seattle tacoma
and
got walked through the airport nobody's
spitting on us nobody yelling at us
nobody calls us baby killers
and we got a taxi
we come in to
and we say hey is there a holiday in he
says yeah there's one downtown so he
takes us to the holiday inn
we all check in our rooms we clean up
we come down to the bar to meet
before we go have some dinner
we get to the bar of course we're all
you know we're all got flight pay
they've paid us before we leave nom and
you know we're all loaded with money
more than we should have had
and we get into the bar and
bartenders say what beef you guys i'm
going to we have our flight jacket zone
you know and they were feeling kind of
smug
and we all ordered drinks and
one of them said hey everybody else's
drink their next drink it's on all of
it's on us
so we all throw in money and we bought
everybody in the bar
that was sitting there their next drink
and there was a
uh couple he was playing piano and she
was singing
and uh they were like the uh
what's that
the carpenters okay that's
and she was singing they were doing all
the carpenter's song
and uh so she dedicated a special song
to us she says he says excuse me ladies
and gentlemen but the next strength that
all of you all
will get tonight are from these four
guys standing at the bar in uniform they
all just returned from vietnam
and
let's give them a round of applause they
all stood up
gave us a round of applause and
then she said i'm going to dedicate this
next song to these guys and it was very
special
and
we didn't buy another
drink that night
we all had stakes they were all paid for
uh and it
they quit playing at one o'clock
and this guy came up to us and said hey
we're a bunch of us are here on the
insurance convention uh we'd like to
take you all out for breakfast
so they took us out to breakfast
and we all got to bed about five o'clock
in the morning
and uh
then we all flew out our separate ways
the next day but i was telling you about
stan dodge stan
parents lived in arizona
tucson
and
he said
and he had left country about a month
before i did
so he said i want to have a little
gathering at my house if you don't mind
staying over
one day before you make it back so i
flew into into tucson
and uh
he had a couple donut dollies there who
were in the 101st
they were there in fact stan married one
of the donut dollars barbara
and terry deegan was a friend of mine
she was there
and plus
uh one guy from bravo company the
kingsman and and another pilot
uh but we partied hardy that night and
stan's parents just did a wonderful job
of uh making us feel at home and and so
on and uh mata's been there two nights i
stayed
because i had to have time to get my
uniform cleaned up before i wore it home
i wanted to make sure it was
strapped when my parents saw me
and uh so i got my uniform got my shoes
all spit shot everything i caught the
plane out of phoenix and
terry was with me and tara and i
had a really nice relationship i mean it
wasn't a sexual thing it was just a nice
relationship we understood each other
and she had left nom two months before i
did and she would write me letters
telling me about
how the world back in the states was not
the world that
was not the real word of her real world
her
what she experienced in vietnam with the
soldier thing that was the real world
and we we would write back and forth
about that
and uh i flew my flight took us she was
from downers grove illinois
so
we flew to chicago and then obviously
catching plane from chicago to charlotte
and
she wanted me to meet her parents
and i wanted to meet her parents too
and uh
yeah i could have probably had a
relationship with with terry um that
would have gone beyond
she ended up marrying an army ranger uh
several years later that she had known
enough
but uh i kept waiting for parents to
come and my flight was coming up to go
and our parents hadn't shown up yet and
i never did get to meet our parents we
finally gave a hug and kissed goodbye
and i got on the plane and
flew to charlotte and that's where my
parents met me
but i i think having those couple days
to
to decompress before i got home
was probably psychologically good for me
yeah that's uh one thing they always
point out world war ii the guys when the
war was over they got on ships and
sailed home together for four weeks or
six weeks and they got to decompress and
tell stories and get stuff off their
chests and whatever and in vietnam it
was like oh you're in vietnam today and
then the next day you're home and you
don't have your friends with you and
you're in random you know main town usa
or main street usa and that that could
be a challenge
so let's fast forward
i was home 30 days reassigned to fort
dixon new jersey
um
not in aviation uh
i was actually working for a facility
that
uh processed awol and deserter soldiers
that were brought back into the army
but every friday night all the aviators
they'd go home take off their fatigues
put on their flat suits
we'd all gather around in one little
portion of the officer club bar
and we'd sit there and we'd reminisce
and
tell war stories and
and uh it got emotional at times
it would smack him on the back oh come
on i'll buy another beer you know
but that's a part of the decompression
and that those were very special times
to sit there and talk about that
and people have often asked me well
what kind of problems did you have and i
said well i really didn't have any
problems when i came back and
and they you know well god you must have
been tough i said well i wasn't tough i
said i think it's just the process of
what
how we all would get together and talk
about our experiences i said these guys
that came back from nam
after being in combat especially
infantry guys grunts as we call them
they would come back they'd go to fort
lewis they'd process out of the army
then they'd go home and they didn't have
an opportunity to sit around and and
many of those were subjected to some
very harsh treatments when they when
they arrived home
and i never had
fortunately never had that experience
so i think the army's learning a lot of
that all the services are learning a lot
about that about how do we take care of
our veterans after they've been i mean
you were in a hell of a lot of horrific
situations
uh
that
that could have mentally had had a
horrible impact on you but you've worked
through that
yourself jackie
yeah i mean i think i always talk about
the fact that i've talked about it
written about it um talk to my friends
about it and i think that's like you
said it's what you kind of got to do and
you know the
i look back now in the first the from my
last appointment for to ramadi um
we got home and
we were we were
we were pretty um
yeah what's a good word here
we were pretty wild when we got back
yeah and and but you know we kept it
under you know we kept we looked out for
each other made sure that we were wild
without you know doing anything that's
going to cause irreparable damage or
cause some kind of major significant
problem but we were definitely wild i
mean there's no doubt about it and then
you know i don't know if it was maybe
six months maybe a year or something
like that you know we started getting
back to kind of just doing what we were
doing a little bit more normal but yeah
we were we're pretty wild when we got
back
well
you know
uh
if my
my excuse was i was well you got pretty
drunk last night i said well i'm an
aviator yeah
yeah we we had some you know we all kind
of a bunch of us lived in the kind of
the same area too same little
neighborhood yeah so we
yeah we would go out we'd meet up and
we'd go we'd go pretty hard
i think uh i think for me i'm still uh
it's amazing the older i get now and
i'll be 76 in august
um
the
the memories become more vivid now
um
i dream about this more
i'm hearing from
people we have a we have our own
commentary website
um
and uh
you can tell by the comments that
lambson 719
had a major
major
psychological impact
on our guys
and there were some guys that measured
their time in service oh i was
oh i came after 719. or i left just
before 719. so see that someone and i
became an anchor
to
describe where one was at one's time
flying with the commanceros
and
when
when matt called me up
and asked me would i uh
do some collaboration on this book
in some ways i was
pleased in some ways i was
a little frightened
to bring up
the experiences and i'll be perfectly
honest i had a lot of anxiety coming
here today
um though i have read this book and a
number of times read undaunted valor 719
quite a few times i've earmarked it
um
i've read after action reports on it
that
hopefully matt and he did he had some of
these uh after-action reports
uh that he took his data from
um
but still sitting here uh
now and talking about it with you
and you weren't there
uh i could talk about somebody that was
there
and uh
but and not have anxiety but
you weren't there and
i often wonder
i'm telling you this
but what are you actually hearing
because you weren't there
and you can tell me about what you did
and i can listen to it but i wasn't
there
and so there's a difference
yeah yeah there's
there's always going to be a little gap
or a big gap depending on you know the
person's experiences
and
you know what one thing i think is
interesting about you know when you
start talking about coming home and what
you're going through
i think the one thing that's good is
if people actually understand
what they're feeling a little bit and i
remember like you get a new guy that's
overseas
and i'd look at a new guy that's
overseas now you could tell they're
nervous right
and you know just say something like hey
man
you're you know that feeling you get in
your stomach and they'd be like
you know trying not to tell you but then
they'd admit to it yeah and i go yeah
you're just nervous it's your it's your
body getting ready to go fight it's
totally normal that's what you should
feel like and they'd be like oh okay oh
you oh by the way you won't be able to
sleep tonight cause we gotta operation
tomorrow you're not gonna be able to
sleep tonight so that's just the way it
is don't worry about it
and i think it's the same thing coming
home you know it's like oh oh oh you're
gonna get you're gonna get sad sometimes
this doesn't mean you're weak it doesn't
mean you're uh trapped in the past it
just means you miss your friends and
that's okay and so if you are thinking
about something and it and it makes you
cry
hey yeah that's what that's what happens
you know it's yeah that's the way it is
and i think if people understand that
that that's
that that's normal
then they go oh okay well that's that's
just what's gonna happen it's okay
and i think when people don't think it's
normal and all of a sudden they think i
can't control my emotions or i'm scared
or um i'm sad and i shouldn't be sad and
i shouldn't be scared it's like no it's
fine no big deal that's just the way it
is you you do your job you you know
you're gonna be scared you got the you
got the queasy stomach you can't sleep
at night okay cool yeah guess what
there's a bunch of other guys that's not
not sleeping tonight either no big deal
no big deal
oh you get home you you're going to feel
sad you're going to miss your friends
yeah we all miss them that's the way it
is that that's okay
and i think that helps people out a lot
to be able to just say okay what i'm
feeling
is not
an isolated thing it's just the way
human beings process
the the tough experiences that they go
through but you know
we both served in
the kind of service that
at one time
you didn't show that emotion yeah
and you weren't expected to
i think the service and i hope
i've read that they have i've seen
interviews that they have
that
now that's been taking consideration
it's okay to express
what you're feeling right now
uh it's okay to go seek counseling
because it's not going to end up on your
officer efficiency report
or your annual report or whatever report
you're going to get
and so i think
that
has been a great improvement
with the way we receive
our warfighting men and women
especially those who have come back and
been engaged in combat
one thing i'll say
about the getting excited and and
nervous about the upcoming mission
and i would do the same thing in vietnam
i mean people said were you scared i
said well hell yeah i'm scared
but hey you know this is what we signed
up to do and this is what we're going to
do and a lot of times
i mean i've said that
trying to convince myself
but see i was a platoon commander i
couldn't sit there and tell my troops oh
my god i'm scared to death
i had to put on
the show i had to do that
but the interesting thing about it is
once we strapped on that helicopter
and
we took off in flight all of that
drained
it all drained i mean it never amazed me
got a job to do
well yeah i mean you were busy you were
monitoring three radios you were you
know talking to the crew there
i mean it all drained i mean
even going into even going into lola
that morning when we were doing 90 knots
approaching we should have been done 60
or 40 and we were coming in there and
but you cycle that thing back in that
damn nose pitches up and you're saying
oh hell i hope my tail rudder doesn't
hit the ground and then you put that
sucker down and you're taking fire all
over the place
you don't have time to be scared
you you re
you react by the training that you've
had and by god that training was good
yeah yeah exactly and that's uh i think
the same way everybody feels i mean if
you're gonna be nervous it's usually
before an operation and for me i was
always just more nervous about my my
friends my guys that's what i was always
worried about hey i hope nothing happens
to guys you know uh but then once
for us it's once the breach goes you
know where once the once the breach goes
now it's on everybody knows we're here
we're doing what we're doing you know
once we leave the gate front gate you're
you're doing your job and there's
no time to think about that you can't
you can't waste any
mental capacity thinking about what
could happen or what might happen
because you got to do your job and you
don't want to have anything else in your
head besides hey what do i need to do
right now
how can i do my best job right now
that's what i'm thinking about
uh but again i seen some nervous new
guys
and just hey man it's all right no big
deal
and and i think that helps people a lot
just like anything anytime you can give
somebody a heads up about what's about
to happen or what i've had this feeling
with uh train training mma fighters
mixed martial arts fighters to go and
fight
and i saw the exact same thing this is
kind of where i started putting together
oh yeah i tell them hey oh your stomach
a little queasy yeah i'm super nervous
yeah you're supposed to be you're
getting ready to go into a fight
it's okay and that would put them at
ease because they'd realize oh this is
just normal this is just me getting
ready to go into you know that form of
sporting combat
i think but but but to add to that i
think it's good to be a little nervous
for sure because you're more on your
game for sure and uh
and that's one thing um
that's one thing general john uh mars
told me uh he was a mentor of mine and
uh
later on in my service and
he was the one that actually encouraged
me to take the civilian position with
the sec death
because i was doing a strategic planning
work for him um
after i had retired from the uniformed
service
and uh we had this
we had this big
strategic planning conference coming up
and
i said sir i'd like to bring dr
so-and-so in from george washington
university and he's been
he's been a a big critical thinker um
he sort of plans okay this is where we
have to be how do we get there kind of a
thing because we were doing strategic
planning you know the vision is where
you want to be now how do we go from
where we are today to make that vision a
reality
and
he
said how long have you been working for
me
i said
about two years sir
he said do you have a phd
i i said there's your master's degree
he said well i trust you i don't know
this guy
and
that's
that's a leadership style that
that breeds confidence
and your soldiers and your employees
i got confidence in you i don't know
this guy
so
doctor what's his name
i never heard him
to come in to do some work for us but
that made me feel great
yeah
so how much longer did you do in the
army before you retired
uh like i said i spent 20 years in
uniform
68-88
then i
immediately uh before that general myers
was talking to me about he said you're
never going to make
colonel
god branch transferred from infantry to
the army's as a general corps which is
administrator for the army
and uh
he said
i want you to take this job the sec deaf
has been impressed with work you've been
doing
and uh
he said your office will be here with me
but you'll be working out of the office
of the sec deaf and at that time i was
with the defense communications agency
which became now the defense information
systems agency but my office was there i
had clients all military clients all
over it wasn't just
communications guys undersec deaf was
one of my clients um the
uh sink u.s atlantic command general
jack sheehan
i don't know if you bet general she had
or the general she had an outstanding
outstanding warrior great leader
general mike still who commanded
u.s army pacific
just a tremendous guy the under
secretary of defense for logistics i got
a chance to do strategic planning work
for him
quite a few organizations in nato
two organizations that shape
uh and that's
that's all because of a guy by the name
of john myers that supported me and
paved the way for me
and he believed in me and uh though i
had
didn't have a phd he trusted me
it's not that what leaders are for
indeed
and then how long did you how long did
you do that for 13 years
and then you
went into what full retirement not quite
well then i uh i was offered a position
in a civilian career in the steel
business
and
i was uh
executive vice president of a uh steel
center
um stayed there from 01 to 09 thought
i'd retire
uh went into the insurance business for
a little bit uh
wasn't exciting
then i decided to retire
and now my fiance
is still uh working
she represents
a company called hancock and more it's
all custom-made furniture uh some of the
most
high quality furniture you will ever
find it's all custom made to
to your specifications
uh leather uh
upholstery uh nails finish frames you
pick out the whole thing yourself and
they build your specifications
uh she also represents a long called
jessica charles an alon called
maitland smith
and our territory is in north carolina
uh so we never go out of north carolina
but uh yeah i say i'm retired but uh
now i run with jan and and i take my
orders from her
and uh so we uh we man her territory
that's outstanding and she's enjoying uh
staying here today because she has
nothing she has to do
that's beautiful things a little
vacation day for a little vacation day
hey before we stop i know there's a
couple things that uh just to mention
here what can you give us the update
i know that i know that colonel
jackson's been working to to sort of
turn this into a movie turn at least
some of these books into a movie i know
there's a gofundme page out there what
what's the update on on on these uh
opportunities
okay well yes
as people should probably know it takes
a lot of money to produce a movie
however
undaunted valor lambson 719
is going to be the movie
and it's our story of those of us who
flew in it who supported it
we need to have this on the big screen
and uh
it's colonel jackson's desire
as well as as mine that this not become
a hollywood
flash in the pan movie this is going to
be
an action-filled movie because lamson
719 was action
and he wants the movie to depict what
actually happened
and if anyone reads the book they will
know that if the movie depicts a quarter
of what's in that book it is going to be
on the edge of your seat kind of a movie
so the events and everything that he's
put into this saying are not hollywood
made up events these are true events
he's changed some names but these are
true events
he does have uh several uh actors uh who
have uh indicated that they would like
to play major roles in the movie uh
there's already a producer on board and
the screenwriters
are busy writing this but it takes money
to do this and the
gofundme
undaunted valor is the place where
people who hear this
and feel that they want this story told
whether it's them themselves or their
relatives who are involved in this or
they are just
very supportive of what our military has
done in the past especially what we did
in vietnam which a lot of those stories
were not very favorable stories
this is a very favorable story of what
we did uh then i encourage them to do
the gofundme undaunted valor
um
all this money uh is going to uh
being
accepted by a 501c3 group uh at fort
campbell kentucky
um and so matt gets none of this money
matt jackson gets none of this money
it's all going towards uh this movie
uh every last synopsis going towards
this movie
um so uh
the quicker we can get this in the more
we can faster we can proceed with
developing this movie and uh i would
certainly encourage uh people to take
this in consideration 501c3 so your
donation is tax deductible
that's outstanding and and
i look forward to uh i look forward to
seeing this thing for sure when it comes
out reading these books sitting here
we're talking with you guys this is just
an unbelievable part of history and
a true look at the heroism
that you all and american soldiers
displayed in vietnam
uh echo charles yes
do you have any questions i do not no
questions from echo charles if he
doesn't ask any questions then that
means he's going to talk a lot later so
i have to put up with that but that's
just the way it is that's part of the
punishment i guess for me no no it just
shows the depth that we went into and
you know how fulfilled i am at the end
okay too down to the detail
right well i want to thank you for uh
asking me to be here and i want to thank
matt jackson for putting it all together
and uh i'm finally glad to meet the man
that i saw on
uh the uh uh
dan bongino show
right on
uh anything else jay no sir
well
again like you said thanks to colonel
matt jackson for introducing us and and
for his efforts in writing these books
and preserving these
these heroic deeds
of our combat aviators and soldiers in
vietnam war and of course thank you for
joining us and sharing your experiences
your lessons learned and most important
thank you
thank you for your service and sacrifice
to our great nation the bravery
of you
of your fellow
pilots of the of the air crews the
bravery that you all showed can never be
questioned
and we are
grateful
for your heroism and the example
that you set for all of us today
thank you
thanks for coming on
and with that
major jay tate has left the building
not even much to say to follow that up
this just mayhem i have a lot to say
actually but i won't go into as deep as
maybe i could but i will say this i was
talking to nick
outside
and
whatever we were talking about it
reminded me of this where
like nowadays it okay not nowadays but
in the vietnam war there are so many
people who did so many crazy things but
they don't have necessarily
a big spotlight on them they're just
like just kind of cruising now
where you don't you know they don't
they're not in the spotlight in any way
they're just like essentially now
they're just sort of just living normal
people well it's always interesting to
me that like uh
major jay tate retired in 1988 i came in
in 1990
right so there's
almost overlap there
and there's been plenty of old vietnam
guys in the seal teams some but you know
i'd be meeting some random army dude you
know and
he could have easily been
this guy you know there are people in
vietnam that did
the craziest stuff and no one knows
about it literally things that are to be
in a movie literally did those things
things that are going to be in a movie
and people will be like oh i wonder why
they wrote it just made it so crazy all
crazy yeah yeah where they got to
suspend their disbelief or what is that
suspension yeah they kind of got to do
that about something that really
happened in real life yeah that kind
meanwhile he's just cruising i mean even
i was talking to tilt yesterday
hell yeah actually saturday i was
talking to tilt on saturday and and he
was you know the amount of
times that
those guys did crazy things
it's unbelievable
it's unbelievable and no one really knew
too much about sog
look if you were if you're deeply into
the military history and all that but a
normal everyday person
barely knows anything about sock yeah i
didn't for sure there's one thing he
mentioned that was pretty dark
and then he just moved right on when
he's like you just you don't want to get
burned up oh yeah as a pilot
well yeah that was in the book that was
in the book lamb psalm 719
yeah he said uh like in world war ii
like some men were known yeah the world
were one before parachutes yeah you
carry a pistol if you don't catch fire
you're just gonna kill yourself
that's how bad it was
yeah that was interesting it was also
interesting in the first book by matt
jackson he's explaining you know
basically that a helicopter doesn't want
to fly yeah yeah this thing does this is
a bunch of metal
gear and oil gears and oil and gas
that doesn't want to fly if you just let
it go it's just going to crash an
airplane even if you let go the controls
it's kind of kind of cruise you know you
kind of feel like i i'm not a pilot i
don't know if you knew that but it feels
like on an airplane
something goes wrong or whatever as long
as you got wings and the in the tail you
can kind of just glide that boy in yeah
it feels like that so i had a car
so my first deployment to guam
barking the dirt when we get over there
all the all the seals we'd buy
guam bombs we call them just like a
piece of junk car whatever you know that
you're just gonna drive around guam for
a few for six months and then sell it to
the next so we bought our guam bomb from
some other team guys that were leaving
we had this it was uh
i think it was a 1977
velarae
it was beige
but here's the thing
cars are kind of you'd think cars would
be like oh
you don't really you know if you if you
don't touch the controls it's just kind
of going to go until it's just going to
go straight to it like stops right yeah
this car i don't know what was wrong if
you let your hands off the wheels it
would go into a full hard right turn as
hard as you could you couldn't turn a
car to the right as fast as this car
would
turn off on its own
that was ours
but also for whatever reason
had
hot
scorching air
you know you know what you know the
little like area
underneath the back window on the old
school cars there's a little area yeah
yeah it's like a back dash yeah you
could throw like a a a pair of slippers
up there or something maybe a t-shirt or
a sweatshirt right it's a little area
like that and there can sometimes be
aftermarket speakers be put in there
right
but there was no there was no
aftermarket speakers but there was just
scorching hot air that came
through those i don't know it's like un
unknown source of massive heat would
fire through that thing so that car was
kind of like a helicopter if you script
your fingers off the controls for a
second you were hitting the right guard
rail in 0.2 seconds
oh yeah so yeah when do you get the
impression and man you probably know
this even firsthand where
just in
vietnam and wartime just in general like
just things are just loud
those things are so loud things are so
much louder in real life than they are
in the movies yes i know that's your
reference
for instance in a helicopter you can't
hear anything yeah it's so freaking loud
it's ridiculous yeah it it's punishing
on your ears it's so loud in a
helicopter yeah the everything is louder
i mean a humvee is freaking loud yeah
tanks are loud everything's loud and
everything's just vibrating it's just
vibrating it's your whole world
yeah it's cool now we got those new uh
ear uh like headsets right that block
out loud noises yeah yeah they can't
noise cancelling the
he said something about when the first i
think it was like the first time where
he
heard the
um the m60 when he was
and i would like vibrate the the thing
and that's what i was like bro the whole
thing is just loud though your whole
world is just loud up there because you
got the helicopter then you get um the
guns and everything's just vibrating and
loud like just hostile the other
interesting thing is
i think of huey's i think of huey's as
being old
right in my mind they're old because i
flew around on huey's and they were old
kind of like when you think of a bomber
right now like a world war ii bomber you
think of this old
you know
those were the most modern beasts of
their time that was like getting those
that was like yeah to a rolls-royce
straight up
so
well um
listen
obviously like i said at the end there
uh guys like major j tate
set a great example for us on many
levels courage
we
you know like for sure
uh capability
i'm not sure what we're doing to improve
our courage what can we do to improve
our capabilities echo charles capability
there's a softball for you knock it out
of the park
do me a favor capability hey okay we're
working out we're on the path
that's it 100 are you say on the program
by the way i'm on the program you know
how like when we're different now your
wife comes home
it's like oh yeah like do you want uh
some extra cheese on the lasagna
you know i said no no i'm on the program
so it's kind of okay i understand you
know
now you're on the path but here's the
thing the path is more broad
more encompassing oh yeah the program
seems like you can easily be off the
program in like three four weeks or
whatever you know it's like that kind of
feeling
it's not they're not hard and fast rules
but i'm just saying the feeling is there
let's put it this way
if you're on
the path
it's a life thing yeah it's like life
yeah you're right exactly programs are
temporary yes somewhat yeah like a
temporary improvement deviation whatever
either way we're on the path
the good thing about the path is sure we
have supplementation but these are
everyday supplementation they're life
supplementation elements so i'm saying
so some of us
back in the day we used to drink energy
drinks
junk energy drinks junk hey it's a new
um it's a new era of energy drink
there's a new era of energy drinks now
healthy energy drinks the kind when you
drink it you get everything front end
you get everything you wanted
energy then on the back end you get
everything that you didn't expect but
want help and you don't get things that
you didn't want jitters no diabetes
chemical
disturbance inside your system some
weird addiction addiction inflammation
and all this weird stuff yeah exactly
stuff we don't want yep none of that
none absolutely none so okay so jaco
discipline go this is the energy drink
if you didn't know already some new
flavors out
which just adds to the choices you have
hey look we all like orange we all like
oranges it's a staple right you're hard
pressed to find someone who doesn't like
orange flavor true yeah cool but do we
love orange some people maybe maybe
wait good deal yeah oh yeah that makes
sense totally makes sense but not all of
us do some of us like more exotic
flavors like mango
mango has the capability to be like
love i love mango orange is more like
yeah of course i like mango or orange
see i'm saying what about the other end
of the spectrum are people more like
well mango's not really my thing i'll
drink orange but mango is not my thing
it's possible
just saying
take one extreme you got to probably end
up with the other one as well it's very
possible nonetheless relationships
nonetheless we're adding to the the
spectrum of desirable flavors in
discipline go so now you got a
win-win-win situation for everybody
three wins three wins okay all day maybe
even four or later i'm just saying it's
always improving this is good it's good
you're better off after you drink one of
these what about watermelon what about
new watermelon what what the salt
watermelon yeah same
same i think that's closer to orange in
terms of people
it being a more
broadly accepted flavor watermelon yeah
you know anyone that does not like
watermelon
i don't know anyone who does not like
you know anyone that does not like mango
yes see
psychos but yes i do know something
uh either way i get it i get it and to
each their own i can honestly say that
with with the ginger you kind of rolled
the dice then with the mango
in a way yeah actually no because when
we chose the mango i chose that because
i personally like it and that's what bee
little kind of said he said hey if you
if you like it that's it so i was like
cool i like it
right on what they seem to like drinks
energy drinks is what you were saying
you can get them yes sir it's a new era
like i said they're good for you the
thing is that's a big deal though
like come on you'd be hard for us to
press to find a good tasting energy
drink that after you drink it you're
better off it's good for you you don't
have to do a bunch of like health
freaking recovery things after you drink
energy you don't go to go on a 14-day
detox
yeah exactly right all right well i'm
super low in calories too by the way
also what else we got extra protein
in the form of a dessert best tasting
protein in the world pretty much
you'd be hard pressed to find a better
tasting protein with that the health
nutrient profile that we have the only
thing that could possibly taste better
as a protein is just steak itself it's
possible
very hard compared to that as we know
you can have a gorgeous
a gorgeous
rib eye steak well marbled tasty cooked
to a tea season to perfect seasoned to
perfection and you can still get done
with that and be like i want something
you want some milk yeah you want exactly
lots of milk bruh that has been me
actually for the last four to three out
of the last four days
hundred percent that's interesting
either way these are all good things
that will keep you on the path and front
end and back end benefits 100 there's
nothing better than more i honestly
there's nothing better than milk when
you get that little
get that you get that
how's this that's the desire here's a
okay so mostly every night there's a
little routine
mostly every night i'll eat a salad yeah
as a meal like a big robust chicken it's
a formula i'll give you the recipe some
other time but it's it's legitimate talk
to me about salad recipes
either way
but
but i'll mix up a milk in there
in the salad no not in the salad with
the salad you drink water or whatever
you drink with salad whatever for some
reason the mulk with the salad is the
perfect combo right before bed
that's in my experience
check
either way also we got other stuff too
for immunity for your joints these are
these are all things we don't want to
worry about on the on this path
we don't want to worry about how strong
our immune system is we don't want to
worry about our joints working or not
working we want to just be sure and be
assured that these things are all the
fire and forget missile exactly just
push the button boom you're good hey
joint warfare
super krill you know
vitamin d3 cold water you just they're
fire and forget don't have to you want
to be thinking about your immunity
system you don't want to be thinking
about your joints if you fire and forget
exactly right if you're on these
types of
supplementation elements
there's only two times you're going to
be
thinking about this stuff
is one when you get on them and they
start working
or potentially if you accidentally get
off that's the only two times you think
about this stuff that's why i subscribe
yes subscribe if you subscribe to these
things you won't go off of them you
won't have that miserable feeling and
you'll you we we you get shipping for
free yeah so that's cool also you can
get this stuff at wawa you can get the
drinks you can get the the
you you're going to wawa and you're like
i need a little energy right now
but i don't want to crash and feel like
crap in three hours cool we got you
covered go to wawa you can get these you
can also get all the stuff at vitamin
shop
as well also in the energy drinks
something i forgot to say which i always
know when i drink them is there's
electrolytes in it mm-hmm get a little
elevated
the pre-workout element in in that is
yeah it's critical check
so yeah also you can get them at
jacofuel.com that's you can get
everything
which is part of origin origin usa so
virgin usa what do they got there
american made jeans
boots
jiu-jitsu stuff
i want to say american-made i don't mean
just american
finished no you know you have grass fed
yeah and then whatever fin it's not the
whole thing grass-fed corn finished or
grain finish yeah whatever the deal is
no
origin's not like that it's from the
beginning all the way to the end
american finished
american started and started yes exactly
right
so boom yes so you got some good stuff
pete's always making some
new
innovative things
you know work pants and whatever pants
are coming i have a pair i have two
pairs actually that's cool because i
don't even have a delta freaking 68
jeans are you serious i am very serious
yeah you got issues i got the regular
ones which have been doing the job
hundred percent but you might want to
try out those deltas it's like you know
what i hate to admit this it's like the
equivalent of a lightweight hoodie boom
yeah there's stuff for that place for
those delta 68s oh yeah for sure
speaking of lightweight hoodies we have
lightweight hoodies i'm gonna come out
with another one i think within the next
three weeks
um
where you can get these things okay so
chocolate store is called jocko store we
have lightweight hoodies if you want to
represent while we are on this path you
can get t-shirts like i said hoodies
light and heavy by the way we've got
some board shorts on there got some uh
some tank tops you know hats cool stuff
on there
representative of the path discipline
equals freedom good all these attitudes
that we hope that we can
run through the path with
okay i'm going to represent
jackalstore.com we have a short
subscription situation new design every
month called the shirt locker that one's
been interesting people who see me part
of the street even today even today
will say hey
i like that that last design i really
liked it one guy said he worked to
church
and everyone was talking to him about it
literally and then which design was that
the the latest one what is the latest
one it's just just this check
oh the period
has the flag on the sleeve it's good it
looks good but it's like you know
there's some layers on there uh
nonetheless yes
so subscribe to that if you want one
every month new different different
types of designs um than the regular
stuff but but good nonetheless and you
can subscribe to this podcast and don't
forget we also have jocko unraveling we
have the grounded podcast we have the
warrior kid podcast we also have the the
jocko underground
[Music]
where we're
doing some alternative podcasts talking
about
stuff in the same vein but maybe a
little bit
tributary
to the scenario that we're usually
talking about we're doing a bunch of q a
there's a place you can send q a and
we're getting through those
uh so go to jacounderground.com if you
want to subscribe to that cost eight
dollars and eighteen cents a month and
we're using that to
create our own
area where if we get booted off of the
big platforms
for whatever reason or they just started
interjecting ads
is that cool
it doesn't seem cool to me you take this
podcast let's say they took this podcast
today and you're in the middle of
hearing about lam psalm 719 all of a
sudden there's an advertisement on there
for a mattress
yeah that's not cool it's not cool no so
if you don't want that cool we got you
eight dollars and 18 cents a month if
you can't afford it we still look if you
can't afford that cool we got you as
well
go to assistance or email assistants at
jockowunderground.com we got you yep
also we have a youtube channel if you're
wondering about the video version of
this podcast we do have a youtube
channel official got some excerpts on
there and the whole episodes got some
other enhanced episodes as well lots of
explosions
i kind of minimized the explosions
lately but it just makes us feel like
we're due for more explosion so you
bring up a good point nonetheless
if there are explosions that's where
they're going to be
like i'll make a regular video and
people will be like i'm uh i'm gutted
literally gutted
by the lack of explosions i was like man
all right i agree with that person uh
yeah it was hard to disagree at the time
i mean you know our explosion's
appropriate at every single situation
maybe maybe not nonetheless if they if
the
explosions are gonna be
present you're gonna find them on this
youtube channel along with everything
else so yeah look up for that
also
psychological warfare if you don't know
what that is it's an album
with tracks of jocko each track is
jockey telling you how to get through a
specific
in general
moment of weakness so if you're in real
in real life if you're having a moment
of weakness which we all do sometimes
but in this album boom choco will tell
you why
you should uh you know
not succumb to the weakness
if you want a
uh
visual representation of this stuff go
to flipsidecanvas.com my brother dakota
meyer selling all kinds of cool looking
stuff that you can hang on your wall
we also have some books hey the books i
talked about today undaunted courage is
the series there's three volumes out
right now
covered one covered volume number one
which is an assault unit as an assault
helicopter unit in vietnam
1969-1970 that's episode 275 of this
podcast covered book three today
lambsson seven one nine
book two is called medal of honor i'm
sure we'll get to that book at some
point
um you can pick up the series of books
they're just an incredible account that
you have to read to really to really
understand the kind of chaos
that was going on
we have a new book final spin i have a
new book final spin it is a
we don't really know what to call it
literature it is literature of some kind
it could be a poem it could be prose
oh it's prose
i don't know there's some very poetic
looking things in there the way it's the
way it's written it's prose elements i
guess yeah
uh you can check that out you you it's
it's available for pre-order right now
i'm gonna say the publisher likely won't
print enough because they're always
looking to
minimize
any loss they're looking to maximize
profit
okay that's cool they're running a
company i get it they don't want to
print too many copies and have some
copies sitting around
so they're going to minimize
they're lowballing it
so that what does that mean to you it
means you end up with second a dish
against the will
brutal and it's cool but at some point
you're gonna meet me
you're gonna come for that i'm not gonna
say i'll sign your second a dish but i'm
gonna know and you're gonna know that
you hesitated at the moment of truth
don't let that be you that's all i'm
saying leadership strategy and tactics
field manual code evaluation protocols
displays freedom field manual way the
warrior kit one two three and four mikey
and the dragons about faced by hackworth
and the
og of my books that i wrote with my
brother leif babin extreme ownership and
dichotomy leadership
leif and i also have a
leadership consultancy it's called
echelonfront go to ashlandfront.com if
you want details on that
we have an online training academy go to
extremeownership.com
if you want to get training if you want
to ask me questions i'm on there
one two three times a week we have a
bunch of of courses that you can take
about these leadership principles so
check that out we have a live event
called the muster the next one is august
17th and 18th i think we're almost sold
out we're getting there las vegas
october 28th and 29th
so go to echelonfront.com and check
events for that stuff
and if you want to help service members
active and retired their families are
gold star families check out mark lee's
mom mama lee she's got a charity
organization where she helps out people
from the military if you want to donate
or you want to get involved go to
america's
mightywarriors.org and if you want more
of my
protracted pronouncements
or you need more of echo's random
ruminations
you can find us on the interwebs
on twitter on the gram
as echo calls it and on that facebook
echoes that echo charles i'm at
jacqueline william thanks once again to
major j tape for coming on today sharing
his experiences with us
[Music]
but of course and more important
thanks to jay tate for his courage and
bravery
in the service of our great nation
and to the rest of the military out
there right now currently serving with
courage thank you for protecting our way
of life and the same goes
for our police and law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service and all first responders
thank you for protecting us here at
home and everyone else out there
our lives that we're living right now
are a gift
and our way of life that we enjoy
it is also a gift it's a blessing and
it's a luxury it's a luxury that we get
to be here
in this world with freedom and free will
and the opportunities that we have which
were given to us through the bravery and
sacrifice of others
do not squander
this gift
and don't waste these opportunities
instead go out there every day
and get after it
and until next time this is echo and
jocko out